This is Jocko podcast number
one 11 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
So yeah,
almost two years ago I had a guy on the
podcast by the name of Jody medic and we
ended up talking for so long that we
actually turned one podcast into two
podcasts. The first one was a review
of his book, which had just come out.
It was called unflinching,
the making of a Canadian sniper,
and then we did a second
podcast right after that.
That was just us talking and discussing
some more of the details of where he had
his life had gone since
that book had come out.
And those podcasts are number 24 and
number 25 and if you haven't listened to
those yet, just stop here, go
back and listen to them first.
And in those podcasts we discussed Jodi's
early life and how he ended up in the
military and his sniper training in his
two deployments to Afghanistan and the
events of January 11th,
2007 when during an operation he hit a
landmine and lost both of his legs below
the knee.
And from there.
Yeah,
he struggled to stay alive,
but he did and he made it back to Canada
where he then struggled to recover from
his injuries and he struggled
to adapt to his new life.
And along the way he struggled to overcome
addiction to pain medications that
had been given to them so freely.
But he did overcome those struggles and
made a new life and wrote a book and got
elected as a member of the city
council of the city of Ottawa.
Yeah.
And he continued to raise his
young girls and take care of them.
And by all accounts, we're talking
about a model citizen. In fact,
I'd go so far as to say
a model human being,
but
things aren't always as they appear.
And although Jodie look to be doing
great by any measure behind that public
persona,
the
struggle continued.
And I saw a glimpse of it when Jody
came down to be on the podcast.
I first noticed it when I
made reservations for Jody
at a hotel by my house and
I just got a nice little hotel nearby
me so I could pick them up easy.
And didn't think much of it.
I gave him the hotel information than a
couple of days later he called me up and
said he needed to transfer to a different
hotel because the hotel that I had
made reservations at didn't
have handicap accessible rooms.
And of course I felt like a like a jerk,
but at the same time I didn't
really understand because
I'd seen all these video
clips of Jody walking around and and
actually running around and he'd gotten
second place in this TV show called the
amazing race where he's doing all these
different challenges and I saw pictures
of him and videos of him running and
driving cars and even riding motorcycles,
driving motorcycles.
So clearly there was something that I
didn't understand that was going on and
maybe he wasn't as mobile
as I thought he was.
And when I went to pick
them up at the airport,
I wasn't really sure what to expect.
I didn't know if he's going
to be in a wheelchair.
to need help getting around.
And as I drove through the pickup area
looking for me, he wasn't hard to spot.
He was standing at the curb,
big beasts s over six feet tall.
And he walked over to the car with
confidence when we really zero indication
that he was walking on two
prosthetic legs and you know,
so we recorded the podcast after
afternoon and it took forever.
It was like five hours or six hours.
And then we got done with that
and we went and grabbed steak
and the next day, you know, he said, hey
can, can you give me a tour of San Diego?
Can you show me, you know,
some of the sites around here.
And so we did that and
I took him down to the,
the buds compound where
the seal training is.
And then I took him to the seal
teams and we went to the USS Midway,
the aircraft carrier museum,
and we were walking all over that.
And then he wanted to go down to
the beach town where I live in.
So we walked around
there and it was awesome.
And he was enjoying it being down from
the cold, frozen Tundra of Canada.
And as we got towards the end of the day,
you know,
Jodie started walking a
little bit slower and,
and I noticed on his face he
had a look of discomfort, right?
That he was, you could see he was
trying not to really reveal it,
but it was there. And then
finally said, you know, can we,
can we sit down for a minute?
These things start to hurt after a while.
And he's pointing down at his legs and
said, of course. Yeah, no problem, man.
So we sat down for a little while and he
recovered a little bit and then we got
up and we walked a little bit
more. And then he said, hey man,
can we sit down again? And I
said, yeah, man, of course.
So then we sat down for a little while
and then when he got up again, he said,
hey, can we just head back to your house
and maybe sit or sit around there for a
little while? These things are starting
to hurt pretty good right now. You know,
the skin wears off and it
starts to bleed and you know,
it's doesn't feel good man. And
I said, yeah brother, no problem.
So we headed back to my house and,
and we went up on the deck and we
sat there and just kinda hung out,
talked and
yeah.
And it became clear to me
something I did know from my other
friends that have been wounded badly,
that it's a lot harder than it looks.
Yeah.
It isn't the bionic man
and it's hard to adapt.
The intermingling of human flesh with
mechanical parts is not a natural thing.
It's not a smooth thing.
It's a battle
and it's a battle that's hard for
us to perceive from the outside.
But it's a battle that takes
place every minute of every day,
usually behind the scenes
privately
because
yeah,
as soldiers,
as marines,
these men learn to suffer and
bear their burdens silently
and without complaints.
And it was here at my house that
Jody explained to me why he needed a
handicapped accessible room. He
said, yeah, you don't matter.
I get home and I gotta take my legs off
and then I got to crawl to the bathroom
to use the toilet and I got a crawl to
get in the shower and I need those little
handles to pull myself up.
Yeah,
it's a struggle.
And [inaudible]
Jodi suffered and struggled again,
not outwardly,
not in public,
but alone.
He pressed on and we kept in touch over
the last couple of years, you know,
text messages and what's
going on and did you see this?
And I sent you that and I watched as
Jodi continued on his journey of his life
and he was awesome to watch and he
got back to Canada and he's started to
podcast and he continued with his
political career and he wrote another
bestselling book called Everyday Heroes.
And
you know, from a distance everything
appeared to be going great.
But again,
things aren't always what they seem.
And behind all that,
Jody was
struggling
and yeah,
a couple months ago I got a text,
a simple text from Jodi and it read,
Bro,
the enemy out flanked me.
Now
in military terms,
that's about as bad as it gets. It means
the enemy has attacked your weakness.
It means the enemy has the upper hand.
It means you have lost
momentum in the battle,
and it means you could
very likely be overrun.
And being overrun means that
you're going to get killed.
And I could see from that text
that Jody was at war again,
not on the battlefield,
but in his life.
But Jody's a soldier.
Yeah.
And Jody fought back because
that's what soldiers do.
Then a little while later,
he sent another text that read on finally
turning into the ambush and starting
to fight through.
He attacked the problems.
He's back on track again back on the path
and came down to visit me.
And after talking to him a little bit
and discussing what he's been through,
I asked him if he would come on
and talk about it. So other people,
not, not just veterans, but
everyone that struggles,
all of us can learn from what he's
been through and what he's overcome.
So here we are once again.
Then with that,
Jodi Jacko,
welcome back to the podcast.
Wow, you had me, uh, and me and I'll
get in the fields there for a minute.
Thank you. Yeah man, it's, um,
thank you for that. You work,
you were talking to me last night about,
about the texts that you had sent me.
Yeah.
And you said, you know, there were some,
there was some heavy texts I sent
you in and I was like, really?
And you said yeah, and I go,
did I pick up on it? And you
were like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I thought you did. Well No, when I
read through my clearly did. Yeah.
And just do the responses and the
conversation we were having, but that,
that first text that you sent
me, yeah. I was like, Damn.
And,
and then I of course I went and
I went back on your social media,
looked at what have been going through
and you dropped off social media. Yeah.
And so you had basically reached
out and said, you know, hey,
brother needs lean,
a little air support over on this side.
And so what happened from,
I mean just you leave here from,
from the last podcast two years ago,
you go back to Canada. Yeah. You Start
Your podcast. That was great. Yeah. Great
podcast. Oh yeah. Uh, got, you know,
a lot of people were listening to it and
getting a lot of feedback from people.
A lot of people hit me like, yeah, Jody's
podcast is great. So you're doing that,
you're working on the other book that
just came, when did that book come out?
October last October. Last October. Hit
the shelves bestseller running. Boom.
Yeah. So when I was already, I was
already hadn't done a podcast since me.
Um, actually, uh, last podcast I did,
it was with some guys from cans off.
Uh,
they started their own company,
tactical beaver if is like supposed to
springboard us into the next podcast.
We had some other guys coming in and
some other cans off entrepreneurs and we
are starting to kind of shift to
supporting veterans in their business
opportunity cause it seems like we're
all becoming entrepreneurs are the guys
that will employ our friends
and things like that.
And that's what I want to focus on is
how do we help the troops after they go
through what I went through
because I had zero plan.
Nobody had really dealt with this
stuff in Canada since Korea. Really.
We had some guys in Bosnia in that,
but the, the chain of command and the,
and the government frankly lied about
the fact that Canadian forces were in
combat, uh, in, in the,
in the former Yugoslavia.
That all aside, the point is we
were, we were trying to lead by,
I always trying to lead by example.
Luke, my, my echo, uh, Luke was,
uh, was trying to help out
and he was doing his best
and he was seeing the wheels
fall off the Jody Mitic machine and you
kept trying to like put them back on and
gun tape them. And, um, just do
as best though because him and I,
it's not like we're like close buds.
Like we're not like besties
since we were kids or anything.
So he's trying to keep his distance and
keep that like Jody Mitic podcast is
Jody medics. And I'm, I'm
Luke. I could tell too.
And I kept telling my friends that,
you know, that we're close as well.
Like I can tell he really wants to help,
but he's not sure. And then one day, um,
so I had a kind of a perfect storm,
so I moved out of my house in
October last October 16 and you know,
I'll just get that out of the way.
That was the beginning really of things
going south. And it's not cause, uh,
my ex and I are enemies by any stretch.
We're still friends.
We have two amazing kids. We had amazing
life. It's just sometimes, uh, you know,
sometimes you'd units don't Mesh Right.
And that's just kinda the way it went.
You know, we both have different visions
of our future and, and things like that.
So,
but then you kind of got to put on the,
the face for the public, you know. Um,
and so I stopped going
to the gym at that time.
I stopped seeing my therapist just cause
he's on the other end of town and I
can't be bothered right now. I've
got too many other things to do. Um,
and even when I was here, like you
said, you saw, I forgot about that walk.
And you're right, I remember sitting
on the wall at visit. It, is it,
is it Ocean Beach Ob.
Yep.
And I love like the Air Americana,
that's what we call in Cam Americana.
History is amazing to me
in the California beach.
Each beach has its own history in the,
in the group I loved.
And you're talking about and I'm looking
around at all these buildings built in
the forties, 50s, 60s. And um, and in
my mind I drove route 66 to get here.
Like I love the history of this,
of this country so much.
And then I was on route 66 until I saw
the pony express trail is to your left.
And I went,
okay.
Turned left and I would follow the pony
express trail down into Arizona. Um,
but even then, uh, like you said,
like the pain was really hitting me and
I'm terrified of the pills because of
becoming addicted. And so, okay,
what do you do for pain if
you're not taking pills? And
I'm not a weed guy. Like,
I know I talk about it and not everything,
but I don't know anything about it.
But I know a lot about Crown Royal,
my Jack Daniels and a and captain
Morgan and I are good buddies.
And uh,
so I found I went from having a
beer after work or in my case,
uh, I like cider. I know I get made
fun of for it, but booze, booze, boys.
So you know what I'm saying? Um, oh,
I can't wait to have that side or after
work or that, that a rum and coke, uh,
when I get to the get to the pub with
the, with the guys, two guys. Now,
the guys that you're talking about now
are your fellow people you're working
with in the government.
A lot of them are politicians,
but also just some of the boys that,
cause Ottawa is like the biggest
military posting and Canada,
but also all the cans offer in that area.
So I got buddies that are coming
back from deployment in Iraq, uh,
on and off. And they come in
for their home for a month.
They're gone for three home for three,
gone for a month. So whenever you get a,
you hear from them,
you run out.
And of course they just got back from
the sandbox so they wouldn't have a beer
or two. And you know, and I'm like okay,
because it might like I'm going going,
going, I get up at six,
put on my suit, go to work,
come home and I'm in pain the whole time.
And from the pain you saw two October,
2016 and then come spring
2017 now it's just,
it's reached points where I wouldn't,
but I was thinking about drinking
before work and it's not,
cause I'm like stressed out and I was
stressed out but is more like, oh man,
like my, cause I, there is a deadening
of the, of the pain for sure.
And it's like, well Uber Ride is only 12
bucks to get to work and this and that.
And,
or my staff drives right by my place to
go so I could have her pick me up and at
discipline kept me from
doing that for awhile.
And then I had a trip to Oregon to go
shooting at the Leopold shooting academy.
They opened there. That was
great. But before I left,
I think I took my legs off for a
solid three to four weeks and as in my
wheelchair and that kind of sucked
because my car isn't set up to drive,
you know, my place I got, which
is like a block from the house.
So it's not that far from the kids in,
in the acts and everything. So you know,
I'm seeing them a lot any way and stuff,
but
nothing else in my life is
set up to live without legs.
Even like where I keep my coffee in
the kitchen is for when I'm on my legs.
So I'm in my, I'm in my wheelchair
the first day and I'm like, oh,
I don't really make coffee when I'm in
my wheelchair. Do I? Oh, tongs, right.
So I get tongs out of the cupboard, reach
off, I can do this, whatever. Adapt.
And it's like, okay, time
to go to work. Oh shoot.
And then I did call my staff and she
picked me up already. Took an Uber,
but then I went to Oregon and that
was a week, like it was about seven,
eight, nine days, nine
days on my leg, straight,
excruciating pain the whole time or
whatever was happening in the doctor.
I finally went back and she said that
like my skin had reached a point where it
couldn't regenerate fast enough.
So we've just breaking down.
And then the way I like to wear my
legs was being rejected by the body.
So I like to wear with,
it gets called a suction as suction holds.
So it's like a vacuum until you
release it with a, with a valve.
And my body was like, well we're done with
this. But I'm like, wow, no, me, no lake,
leg, leg sleeve, legs, sleeve takeaway,
mobility, Mino once. And so my,
you know that if you're going to be dumb,
you better be tough. Thing comes in,
you gotta be telling. Yeah.
And you know, and, and, and,
and I didn't have it and I'm not living
with, with a medic anymore, right.
So she's not there to be like,
hey, stupid, but yourself,
like take the legs off and
let someone take care of you.
My mom actually moved to Ottawa December
16 and I'm completely ignoring her
advice because you know what, mom, mom's
always going to try and look after you,
but come on mom, I'm
40 years old Jews. Um,
and I was pushing away against a lot of
the same things I would then in the same
day would tell people like, hey man, you
gotta let people look after you. You know,
cause I get texts, I've
probably same as you, right?
I get texts bbms I get dms on Instagram
and Twitter and Facebook on my fan page
and then the podcast page, uh, hey, what's
going on? Like, I need help with this.
And I'd be like,
don't be afraid to go get help.
Don't be afraid to reach out those around
you. Love you. Let them look after.
And I'm completely ignoring any of
this advice myself cause I'm like,
I kicked oxycotton when I was 22,
I think.
And on deployment I stopped smoking
just because I wanted to. Uh,
I drink on the weekend, I don't
need to drink. But meanwhile,
while I'm sitting there checking
these messages while having a drink,
I know and I look back and I'm like,
I'm so stupid.
But I guess sometimes
you got to go through,
there's a reason why you go
back to basics. Is there,
is there like in your mind
when you're going through that,
are you thinking yourself,
I could stop if I wanted to do every day?
Just don't want to, yeah, I don't, it's
not getting in the way of anything.
I'm still functional. I'm still
at work. I'm still doing. To me,
my main job was what I was elected to do.
Right.
And I have a four year in my mind it's a,
it's a,
it's Kinda like being in the
army where you're on four year,
four year commitments,
right? So I'm like, well,
right now I have a four year commitment.
I'm not drinking at work.
I mean at some point I did
start drinking at work,
but in politics and business as you know,
like sometimes after lunch,
instead of going back to the office,
you have a beer and you're still working,
you're still talking about issues,
you're still getting,
like I used to get a lot of advice
from, I shouldn't say used to. I,
I get a lot of advice from the other more
experienced politicians because that's
what you do.
And we all would have a beer or a cider
and then they'd go back to the office
and I'd stay and keep on the
phone and now I have one more,
you know? And then another group of
guys would come in from like, oh, hey,
you're still here. Like, you know, so
and so's already back at City Hall.
What kind of,
what kind of drunk are you happy?
I'm a happy go lucky I get a little
loud, but it's not like I'm like, Hey,
what's going on? Better? Um, but you know,
anyway, well I know it to your ass. No,
I'm actually just asking. You could,
you could still call on the phone and
be like, hey buddy, blah blah. You know,
some people when they
drink they get angry.
Some people I know they slur their speech
really bad and so you've got all these
different,
you drams when I drink I basically
just like am more of Jocko.
Yeah. I'm more Jody. Yeah. For the
most part I do slur, but even I could,
I'd be like, ah, I'm
slurring my words. Okay,
well I'll drink some water for a minute
and then I'll get it back or I'll have a
coffee. Um, and I'm good. I'm not,
I'm normally, and even when I'm like,
I rarely get fall over
drunk. Right. If ever,
but just let me rewind. I know that's
a long answer to a short question,
but so may I get back from
Oregon and I'm just like dying.
And then I had to go
real quick down to ebony.
Cause of part of my job with the city
is I'm the sports commissioner and I'm
desperately trying to get the crossfit
games to bring the eastern regional games
to Ottawa because I just think that'd be
awesome to have an Ottawa. We, you know,
we've got the UFC in Ottawa.
I was a part of that.
And so I was really proud and
I said when I got the job,
I said I want to do two things in the
four years at the UFC and get the crossfit
games. So I'm still trying
to do the crossfit games.
I got less than a year to do it, but
I think we can do it. But anyway,
that's a lot of people that participate
in crossfit that listen to this podcast
maybe. Yeah, I've met a lot of them.
And you know what? The crossfit guys,
a crafty and Albany city itself, they
don't want to lose the crossfit games.
So they knew I was in town and
they started to sweeten the deal,
if you know what I mean.
And the crossfit games go well,
auto was offering us this. Albany, what
you got? Hey, it's business. I get it.
But you know what, I'm coming back. Um,
I got back from that trip that was about
a four day trip from Ottawa to Albany
and back.
And when I was here with you guys,
I didn't bring a wheelchair began.
That's what I meant by I crawl around,
which is why I could stay at your house.
But I don't want your kids seeing
a grown man crawl to the bathroom.
And it's not because I'm above crawling,
it's just,
it's one of those personal
things in my own space.
I'm not above it and around
like loved ones. Okay.
So that's why you want your own
space and even a and stuff like that.
So even when I visit my dad,
I get a hotel room, you know,
my dad loves me and I'm not,
but it's also my space or if I want
to crawl around naked, I can write.
And so anyway, that's why
that, so then I get back and,
um, I take the legs off and I'd just,
I can't put them back on. I look,
I would like, I don't know, I
said it on your show last time,
but I have mornings where I look at
my prosthetics. I'm like, fuck, sorry,
sorry for swearing.
I know we were allowed,
but I'm trying to be a little bit bit
of a remand Deco, you know what I mean?
You're going to be an echo.
I don't want you having to edit
out things that I say. Okay. So,
um,
I took them off and I just looked,
I just threw him across the
room and I said I can't deal.
I have a wound in my left stumped.
I did I show it to you? No,
it's been there since April of 14
and it happened.
I remember the second it happened.
My brother and I were doing an amazing
race thing post show in Alberta and we
did a little like, you know, go, Hey
Jodi and Corey from amazing raise woo.
We got a few bucks for it.
And we gave a speech to a,
some kind of convention and then I was
walking down the airport to the plane and
I felt something go on my foot.
It's,
and it's like having a hotspot when
you're on a rug merge or whatever except I
can't really shift what part of my
foot and walking on, I just can,
and it went from a little
tiny like breaking the skin
to something the size and
Canada. We have two knees, it's $2.
I know you guys still use the dollar bill
like a 50 cent piece and then back now
it's down to like a pinprick of scab.
But that's what are we talking now
where uh, almost four years. Right.
And I had to mitigate that the whole time
and it was painful and I got a couple
of, I got to infections
in the four years from it,
but that's where I was like that's it.
I need to let myself heal.
I need to like let my body
regenerate except now from that.
And it took me until fall late fall to
realize that when I did that I might as
well have stepped on another landmine.
And I went through,
it took me to late fall
to go cause I was like,
cause that's when things really went
south because you basically not even
basically because you lost your legs
again. Yeah, I lost my legs again.
Except because truly when you were down
here, even though you're in pain bro,
we were doing, you
know, we were walking up
and downstairs we were,
we're doing whatever.
We walked all over that aircraft carrier
over that aircraft carrier up and
downstairs we walked all over the seal
compound. We walked through, you know, we,
I loved it.
I went out on the beach when we walked
out on the beach where you guys torture
the, the recruits, trains
every step. I was like,
cause you've got to dig through the sand.
But to me that's hollowed ground burrow.
Like when you took me to the grinder,
I remember standing there like
this is the grinder. I'm Katie,
I'm Canadian army and but there's
some things where you go, you just,
you feel right.
If I brought you up to the recruit
spot and for basic and Canadian army,
you'd be, you'd feel, you get that feeling
like this is where soldiers are born.
There's been a lot of those little,
they have the little fins on
the grinder stuff like what,
what Jody's talking about is where are
they trained seals that first day in the
movies, right? Yeah, it's,
it's, and they have little fins,
so like little dive fins. There's
little 40 you know the marine corps,
they have boots. Yeah. Yeah.
He in the army, they have
boots painted on the ground.
They paint them on the ground. Well
in the ad, the grinder at buds,
they have little swim fins to
little tiny swim fins are painting.
There's a couple of hundred of them.
And that's when you get out there for PTU.
Stand onto your little set us when tents
and then as the days go by there's less
and less. He is great.
And then, and I've read,
I've read if I've read less
than 24 navy seal books from,
from the beginning to today. Right. Yours
included. I'd be surprised. I've read,
I've read the, uh, the old blurps
right. I've read about those guys.
I've read about the original rangers.
I've read about the Canadian,
I'm a American special service for us.
Actually when I was with rob,
my buddy from the green berets down in
Yuma, I was wearing a ranger up tee shirt.
That's like a special service
for us. Tribute, you know,
to me like that's our history.
That's the history of, of, of,
of soft and Canada in the u
s and, and then, you know,
in Buds and new Greenbury or navy seals.
The green berets are kind of created by
Kennedy at the same, see, look at me.
I'm a fucking nerd when it comes to
this stuff. So to me, you know, the, uh,
I haven't been there,
but I've heard about it because a lot
of my friends that had been there,
the Aussies, they have a parade ground,
like in the middle of their compound.
Have you been there? No, I've never
been to Australia. They're the,
the only time they use this parade ground
apparently is at memorial services for
their men. Yeah. And I believe
that no one walks on it.
It's just in the middle of their compound.
No one walks on.
In Canada we have a similar thing where
if you're on the parade square and it's
not parade,
like you're going on extra duty.
Like if the sergeant major catches
you on his parade square a,
you better be have a broom in your
hand or you better be on parade.
And if you're not like, cause
it's, cause it's usually like,
oh if I go from here to there,
it's right across the print screen,
but it's the short route and
it's like one of those tests,
right then the new guys in the
hallways of most units, the unit, uh,
emblem is in the floor and there's one
of those sergeants that just has nothing
better to do but to stand there
and watch and see who steps on the,
and even if you're like family
of one of the troops, oh my hair by
drip bro. And you get the knife hand,
it's awesome.
But when I was here,
I wasn't gonna not go see the
grinder cause my fucking legs hurt.
Don't be a pussy. And I, I'll be honest,
that first night after you dropped me off,
I had a couple of drinks
to ease the ease the day.
Like when we left your porch and you draw
me back at the, at the hotel. Yeah. Um,
I, I went and I had a few drinks at
the hotel bar, you know, and I, and I,
I was actually toying with talking to
you about this stuff back then because it
was bugging me then and I'm like, okay,
what do I do? Who do I talk to? Tacos?
A kind of guy echoed is the kind of
energy you want to be around. And like,
you know,
and that's one of this part of this,
this trip for the last 10 days I've
been on is just kind of like refining.
So a lot of my Canadian and American
friends that have kept me on,
on the straight and narrow
or as I mentioned, you can
did for Jody Mitic and um,
you tell bro, it's a constant
wrestling match, right?
The little evil and the good angel,
except a lot of times they high
five each other. And Go, okay,
let's see what happens.
And um, and yeah, man,
so when the legs came off,
so no car.
So now my mommy Uber or my staff
or my ex are driving me around,
all happy to do it all. Not like holding
it against me, but at the same time, man,
I, I'm out of sandwich meat. Hmm, okay,
now I need to go to the store.
Hey Mommy can,
can you drive my car and take me
to the store? And then that's,
I kind of turned my hat backwards and
kind of like, you know, tried to like,
you know,
cowboy up and do it.
But I took me again until then.
My daughter turned nine,
September 19th,
I think it was her,
I missed a lot of her birthday from being
hung over and she was at this awesome
trampoline place and I'm in a wheelchair
and I remember getting there and being
like, all I want to do right now
is jump on trampolines with my,
with my little girl and I can't,
a and B,
I'm an hour and a half late for her party.
Uh,
because I decided to have too many
drinks last night and that was when I was
like, what the fuck is really wrong with
me? Because I couldn't really get it.
And then what is,
what is the
escalation? Right? So you were
down here with me. Yeah. You know,
we worked hard. We cause it's, it
is, you know, do you want a podcast?
Like when we do sit there and talk to
each other about intense stuff for five
hours, then we went and
ate, we stayed up late.
We get up early the next day we go do all
the stuff that we did and you get done.
You have a couple of drinks,
right?
What does that escalation look like over
time? Where you're like, you know what?
You're not even saying like, oh, I don't
know if I should have drinks. You're like,
hey, as soon as Jocko gets in his car,
I'm getting some drinks right now.
It's something that you recognized.
Is it something that you just,
you just said to yourself,
you know what?
This is gonna make me feel better right
now and I've got to go to God. God,
I don't remember exactly
what month I was here. Do you
like, I don't remember. No, I know it
was a warm month and ah, and Canada leg.
It was cool.
But it was spring or fall.
Well we started in December.
It was 24 podcasts in that
December of what?
2015 so must've been
spring Fort 15, 16. Yes.
16 so I,
cause I remember in Canada wasn't cold,
but like we were wearing still
wearing down vests with food,
with hoodies and stuff. Uh, when I
was doing my quick podcast for I left.
So at that time I was,
it was just,
the pain was just kinda like have a
couple of drinks before bed. Right.
But even that was bugging me and
that's what I mean like when I was,
but then like if,
if,
if it had been this spring where we
had met, yeah, I would've been like,
like this the whole time.
And like as soon as Jocko has gone,
I might've just like last night when we
had dinner, I might have just been like,
fuck it,
I'm having drinks.
I don't care if Jack was here because
being around someone like you,
like I used to be the guy who could,
I don't need to drink.
I'd go months and be like, oh yeah,
I haven't had a drink. Like you know,
I'll have a drink and,
and you don't drink and you haven't drank
since you were like in your twenties I
think you said.
No,
I haven't drank since I retired. Oh, okay.
So last time I felt
the effects of alcohol,
which I felt quite strongly that the
basically the day I retired. Yeah,
you're the day I retired,
which was October 1st,
2010 you know,
of course me and the boys were,
went out, we had a bunch of drinks.
I woke up in the morning cause I still
wake up early and I woke up in the
morning and I was like,
well yeah,
that's done because I got
other stuff I got to do now.
And basically when I no longer had
we'll call them friends to drink with.
Yeah. Then I was like, yeah, well I'm done
with that. And I just ever since then,
just haven't really,
I've had,
and another thing is sometimes people
think I'm like offended if they have
drinks or whatever and I'm here, I'm not,
you know, I remember actually I went,
I was on the first podcast I was on was
Tim Ferriss and we got done with the
podcast and he,
you know,
we went out to grab some food because I
was staying the night at his house and
we went out and we got some food,
we've got some steak. And he's like,
do you mind if I have a glass of wine with
this? And I was like, Bro, I don't care.
You.
Yeah,
yeah. Like a reformed alcoholic. You
just decided one day you're like,
my dad one day he was like, Eh,
this gets in the way of work.
Yeah. That's Kinda, that's kind of my
attitude isn't really. Yeah. I mean,
if I want to drink something that tastes
good, then I'll drink chocolate milk,
which I love the taste of. Yeah.
The Jocko white tea. Right. I mean,
that stuff makes me feel
good and I just, um, yeah.
And people ask me about a lot and I need,
it's something that I need to address in
the podcast because the other thing is
just, I might as well dive into this
a little bit right at this moment,
but when I was a kid,
I was into hardcore music I was into,
and the type of music that I listened
to was against drinking and against like
it was, yeah, yeah. We're
talking straight edge.
We're talking minor threat.
Yeah. Really? Yes, absolutely.
And so it was almost, and I was,
again, I was never really, I'm very,
I'm very,
I'm not a real good follower.
So any time there's some kind of a
movement going on, I'm always like saying,
wait, why is this move and going, why am
I always questioned? I don't just jump in.
I'm hard to get on board
with something like that.
So it was around, I wasn't
like, so there's a, there's
a thing with straight edge.
Okay. So this, this thing was
called straight edge. It started in,
I'd say you'd see the,
the epicenter of it was in Washington DC.
The first band really to coined
the term was minor threat,
which is a punk band,
a heartburn if I've heard of them,
I assumed they were partiers. No, not at
all. No. And so one of the things that,
one of the symbols of straight
edge was, uh, you know,
when you go to a bar or when kids
used to go to bars for a show for a,
for a music show,
if they were too young to drink once when
the bounce all looked at their ID card,
that they'd put a big x on their hands.
And so the straight edge I'm symbol
was they'd put the x's on their hands,
meaning look,
I don't drink.
And it's actually funny cause I took my
two of my kids to see the white buffalo
the other night in San Diego and it
was awesome. And, but when they came,
when they show their ids, they got the x's
on their hands. And I was like, Oh yeah,
it always is.
So what the straight edge kids would
do is they would draw big x's on their
hands, meaning, hey look, I'm
not drinking. So there was that.
And then that of course morphed
into like a gang. And there was no,
by the time I was, uh,
you know, middle teenager,
there was hardcore gangs that would
assault people that drank and would get
crazy and vinyls guys and together with
the Juggalos. Yeah. So it just, so,
so, so when I was a kid I was
okay and I wasn't like a full on,
I wasn't drawing. I don't think, I know
I never like had x's on my story, but I,
but I understood philosophically,
right. What was being said, right.
Which was, look, I want to
win. Right. I'm hardcore,
I want to be stronger,
I want to be aware,
I want to be alert and drinking and
doing drugs doesn't give me any of those
things. So at that, at that,
so sorry, but even at that age,
you understood the fuel that goes into
the machine affects the performance. Yes.
He, I didn't get that as a young man.
Yes. So here I am. And, and it was,
you know, I was disciplined and you
know, I had a before the seals. Oh yeah.
I had a band,
a hardcore band.
The name of my hardcore
band was rage of discipline.
That was the name of my hardcore
band. That was af. That's what,
that's what Bronson's children.
Cause my first band when I was like
13 was called Bronson's children.
But then as I got older I
got more hardcore than it
became a rage of discipline.
There was also about nine, it's
brunch. These children Bronson,
she bronzes Charlesville he didn't drink,
I don't even know.
Oh [inaudible] name.
We do know Charles Bronson was a bad ass.
And when I was a kid
I thought Charles Bronson
was the man because he's the
baddest man on the planet.
He was a tail gunner in a,
you know,
bomber in World War II. And he grew
up in the mines when he was a kid,
when he was 10 years old or 11 years old,
he was working in the mines.
And until he was old enough that
he used to have to wear a dress,
cause he didn't have parents that
have money to buy him clothes.
So you had to wear one of his
sister's dresses down to the mind.
So then he went to World War II
and then he became, and you know,
he's just had great movies and he always
played this stoic character that was on
emotional. And so I was, you know, hey,
when I grew up I to be Charles Bronson
of course. So then we had a band,
it was called Bronson children.
Well, as we got more hardcore,
eventually that name morphed
into rage of discipline,
of which Elgin James was the guitarist,
who's another buddy of mine.
That echo is met,
who will come on the podcast at some
point and tell his crazy life story,
which I'm a big part of in the
beginning until I joined the military.
The military Jocko stories.
Yeah.
So I'll be tuning into that one long
story. Then I joined the military. Yeah.
So when I joined the military,
what do I want to be? I want to be,
I want to be a seal.
I want to be a frog man.
I want to be the best frogman I can be.
I show up at a seal team.
Guess what frogman do frogman drink.
Okay, cool. I didn't know that.
Now that I know that,
give me a,
give me a shot of Jagermeister
cause I'm ready to rock and roll.
And that was sort of how you proved
yourself and that's what we did.
And I was immature and dumb and,
and despite everything I just said
about like, Hey, I'm a little bit,
I'm hesitant to really follow,
well now I'm in the seal teams,
this is my dream job and this is what
I want to do. Maybe you don't buy in,
you're not in. Yeah.
And it's like it's not,
I don't even know if it's it just
like that's the way it is. Yeah.
My first drink I was 17 right
after I finished basic training,
I show up at the regimen and they're
like, all right, what are you drinking?
And I'm like,
cause my family is full of alcoholics
on both sides and it's nothing against
them. Like, you know, Grandpa was,
my other grandpa was and Grandpa's Grandpa
was and you know, one of my uncles,
nothing. Okay. They might hear this but
we all know what you do. Okay. Right.
So not a big deal, but um,
and dad, but dad was one of
those guys, he was like, well,
that just doesn't affect me. And me
personally, like you as a kid, I'm like,
I don't really see the interest.
Like what I gotta throw up on
myself and whatever, whatever.
And I was one of those kids that say no
to drugs, actually worked on, you know,
like now I'm older and I'm like,
man,
I should've been smoking weed since I was
like 12 and shit. But, um, I still don't,
but I did. I just like, you
see the effects on people.
Like when I was a Bouncer,
I'm like, yeah, like the guy who
smoked weed, we're really mellow.
And the guy that had coke and drank, like
they were the ones who are the problem.
But, um, when I get to the regimen,
the first night of parade is done and
they're like, Hey, what are you drinking?
And I'm like, well, I'm 17.
They're like, this is an army
mess. Like it's okay, just,
we'll worry. We're all going to keep
an eye. Like you're welcome to look.
I'm not trying to tell the world
like, Hey, underage people drink,
but hey Andrades people drink.
But it's an environment full of people
that are there to look out for each other.
Anyway, so I had a couple of drinks and
I'm like, okay, this is the way it is.
And same thing. Yeah. Work Monday to
Friday, you work your ass off, you,
you go hard as you can. Like you
go hard in the paint, right, your,
your tires or are stripped at the
end of the day. Friday rolls around.
Okay. We don't see it. 8:00 AM
Monday morning boys and uh, you know,
if you're going to drink, don't
drive. But if you do drink driver,
that's what you got told when you, when
you're dismissed for the weekend. Right?
Yeah. And so basically have
fun, blow off the steam,
don't hurt anybody and take care of
each other basically what you're told.
So the seal teams definitely is a culture.
It was even more when I first got in
because now you're talking about the old
Vietnam guys and it wasn't a war
going on and it was just, hey,
what are you going to do if
there's no war going on and you're,
you're a frog man, what are you
gonna do? Well, we drank and I'm not,
I'm going to look down on, I mean, we had
a great time. It was funded. We, you know,
it was, it was fun. It was
what you did was what we did.
And I'm not even trying to say
anything negative about it,
but that's what it was. And
unfortunately, there's a lot of guys,
I shouldn't even say a lot.
There's a decent number of guys
that don't do well with alcohol man.
Yeah. And it ruins, their lives are
ruins their careers. And that sucks.
It sucks to see. I never really had
any issues. I drank when I drank.
It never interfered with my one here
at the time in any way. And you know,
that was it. It wasn't a huge deal. And I
mean, of course, I mean when I'm talking,
when I was 1920 2122,
I mean we drank all lot.
We drank all lots of weird how your
body legs, you're at that age. Yeah.
And you got up the next morning, the
next morning PT like it was nothing we,
and that's what we did. Um, but then like
I said, and even now, you know, when I,
when I go out and hang out with some of
my old buddies or actually it's more not
want to just go and hang out with
some of my old buddies, you know,
we probably don't even, you
know, maybe have a beer.
But when I go out and see the young guys,
the young guys are getting after it,
I don't look down on them at all. I
think, you know, fine getting after it.
I've found, I've found when I hung out
with my buddies that are still serving,
you're not in the gig anymore.
You're not doing the job.
So you're a little out of shape.
Your,
your drills are a little rusty
maybe or whatever. I find on,
I'm around guys my age
that are still operational.
I can't keep up with them drinking or
because it's part of the training is part
of the culture. I've fallen off.
And even like before I was in,
I didn't really drink. And then when
it got out I stopped drinking as much,
you know, and it's not like, again guys,
we're not Jocko and aren't saying the
military were all functional alcoholics.
What we're saying is it's just what we do.
And you know,
and remember the job that
we volunteer to do, we,
we volunteered or run into gunfire, uh,
you know, for our countries and for fun,
like let's face it,
a lot of us think it's fun.
I thought it was the best time of my life,
but he's still got a blow off that steam
and booze is really good at lubricating
the, the, you know, the, the, the,
the machinery of blowing off steam.
So when I, when I started drinking
for pain though, as where I realized,
cause even the pills bro, like,
let's go back to my pills.
I didn't know I was addicted to
the pills until I watched uh,
intervention and Billy was addicted
to Oxycontin. I was, like, I said,
I said this on the show last time.
Oxycotton that sounds familiar.
And I pick up the pill bottle that's next
to me and I go, Oh, I'm on Oxycontin.
And then they say the doses,
he takes her this, I'm like,
I'm on three times the dose he's on.
And I'm like, that's when I went,
I can get addicted to pills I get,
it was so foreign to my brain that
doctors doctor meet me and pain doctor go
here, soldier would take this and I
go, okay. And I take it no more pain.
Go fight more. You know?
That's, that's good.
Going back to the alcohol
thing is one more thing for me.
I was just about to say
this was, I said, hey, look,
went back in the day before the war
started, there was like nothing else.
Like yeah, there's nothing better to
do. Who's going to get drunk? Now,
the younger guys,
they're smarter than we were and
they have a reason to be doing,
they have a reason to be there and they
have a reason not to drink. They're like,
hey bro, I'm going to go fight a war.
You know, like I want to be in shape,
I want to be better, I want to be
faster. I don't want to get in a fight.
I don't want to get a Dui.
So they're smarter than they are.
And that part of the culture is
slowly changing and I think it's good.
I think it's awesome. I think it's awesome
and I hope it continues. Um, again,
I think it's,
it got overemphasized when I first
came in over emphasized in the 90s.
It was like, but it was a way because we
weren't fighting anyone else. Exactly.
So you drank to be a man and then you
fight each other and have another platoon
shows up.
You fight.
Those fucking guys have another squad
shows up or another company. Alright.
Band together. I know we were just
fighting, but we'll get back to that.
But there's a wreck.
It was an armored regimen over there.
We're going to go fuck those guys.
Others,
there's something that I've been
thinking about on this subject,
which is in the military, right?
Yeah. And even in life as a human,
you want to prove that you're ready
to sacrifice yourself for the cause.
I'm,
I'm willing to make the sacrifice.
Well in a bazaar and kind of
unfortunate way proving to Jody that,
you know what, watch this, Jodi, I'm going
to drink 16 show. You're not firewall.
You're nice. I'll,
you're not, I don't care.
I would have the parts bitch and then
we'd go, oh, then I prove light up.
18 line up 18 army versus navy. Let's
go. That's how it's fuck away. It goes.
Echo, Echo. You played football. Yeah. You
were talking about that earlier about, uh,
are on the show.
I was listening to do.
You were taking a shit with no stalls
and you're saying, yeah, and football.
We'd rip the doors off the stall and
that's how it, oh, well I don't care.
Watch me. Shit. What's, what's
more aptly the word now?
What's more apt to happen now as a guy
to be like, hey, I can clean and jerk,
you know, two 85 what can you get?
And, and, and so the guys are,
they're focused on something that fit
is focused. They're blown out. Shoulders
and knees. Yeah, we'll talk
about that later. But so,
but I get what you're saying.
Cause in the Canadian Forces,
we hadn't had a war since
Korea and we had the,
what combat we had as I was coming in was
being downplayed. We had guys take it,
we had a guy, and this is
history, this is proven.
He took an RPG round through his chest,
like just killed him
obviously and everything.
But his family is told he was killed in
a rollover because our government was
like, they're supposed to be peacekeeping
wasn't in the former Yugoslavia.
And I know a guy who took a sniper round
through the chest as a tank commander.
He was told to shut the fuck up,
take your pension and your benefits
got full benefits. Like it didn't,
they didn't downplay what you've got
if you're wounded. They just said,
don't you dare tell anybody.
We had a,
we had a unit come home
after like fighting some of
the most intense combat in
Europe since World War Two when the
Croats are trying to go through a service
area and ethnically cleanse.
And this is in the 90s when the Canadian
like rep for peacekeeping really got,
which was known since Egypt,
but came back because our units and the
French Foreign Legion units where the
only units that were like,
fuck you are not moving if you're
going to f ethnic cleanse through here,
you're going through us.
Whereas all the other UN units ran away
and they were in four or five days of
like intense combat, bunch of
wounded, know killed thankfully,
but the government and the,
and the and the chain of command where
like shut your fucking mouth, go home.
Like nothing happened.
That's real. That's real bro.
Google made act pocket Canadian Forces.
And you'll read all about these dudes
who just like basically were like hanging
out, drinking coffee, smoking
butts, and telling war stories that,
that never happened to be an in a war
and going, Holy Shit. A buddy of mine,
um,
he's gonna get mad at me.
He put out a book called shadow keeper or
ghost keepers. I'll, I'll get the name,
sorry. And I'll, I'll, and he
was the first Canadian unit.
Him and his unit were the first Canadian.
It's into Bosnia and the shit they
saw and the things they went through.
It's a great book by the
way. It goes. Keepers. Um,
why would he be mad at you for talking
about it? I'm forgetting the name wrong.
Sorry about that. But the point is
that at that time he was told like,
you don't tell, we don't, we don't
Brag is what the line that was told.
But really the government
back home was like,
we didn't know this was going to happen.
Well,
you don't piece keep without busting
heads. Like there's a reason if you,
if I want to go kill that
guy and you're in my way, um,
well guess what I'm going to do?
I'm going to try and go through,
you write like this concept
of peacekeeping and you
know, it was like, you know,
like the guy with the Billy club. All
right. Okay. Everybody keep it down here.
See like,
that's kind of what the politicians
thought because we were college kids
sometimes. Yeah. But even
then, every now and then, yes.
Smack one over the head with that
Billy club like, and I think,
and I remember my first tour in Kosovo,
even we trained for crowd control.
We trained for
a whole lot of things,
but then the final training
exercises when we all went, oh,
because the Russians rolled in and
took over the airport in Kosovo.
I don't know if you remember that.
Yeah.
And we did a live training
exercise to a joint, um,
uh, armored, a full combat team exercise,
like main battle tanks
firing. And like, I'd never,
my Dick was rock hard and you were a five.
We've got 500 rounds on each other.
We're just like bullets flying
everywhere and like, uh, like Ray,
the range control safety was like minimal,
right?
Cause they're like trying to simulate
real combat. And then we got, but anyway,
the point is that when you don't have
anything to point your soldiers at,
they turn on each other. And that's
what we were getting at earlier.
But to round out the whole, like what
soldiers board soldiers are a danger echo.
I think if you've been around a
group of active navy seals, I think,
or maybe even army guys, like if they
got nothing else to fight though,
just fight each other like we used to
whenever we're waiting for a plane to go
on a trip like this upon my youngest,
like it would start off with, okay,
let's see, you can hit that pole
over there with a rock. Yeah. Right.
And then all of a sudden
it's like, okay, let's see.
You can hit the light with the Rock and
then all of a sudden it's, hey, let's see,
you can hit that car tire with a rock.
And pretty soon years hired, is it
whoever you bunch of idiots. Right.
And pretty soon you're either having
a rock fight, right, which is,
which is not smart because you're hocking
rocks the size of baseballs at each
other or whatever. Yeah, and
we were talking about wisdom,
the newer guys see how we did it. But they
have an enemy though. Yeah, absolutely.
Like they have,
we have a perpetual enemy that is not
going away and so I see the guys that are
in my unit now, they come
in and they're like, okay,
what supplements are going to keep me at
my best? Zack? Like they read my book,
they go, okay, so Jody, you'd
stopped drinking coffee.
How many days before you deployed?
I'd be like, well at least five days.
So it's out of my system because when
I'm out there getting after the enemy,
I don't want to be having
a caffeine crash, but if I
need it, I want that piece.
Did you ever get that wake
up gum in your rats? No.
It's like four cups of coffee in one
or two cups of coffee and like when you
need it, like I would keep that
in my pocket till the very end.
Like the Hilo might be coming to pick us
up and if I didn't take it, I was happy.
But sometimes, yeah, you take that in
the middle of a mission and you're like,
okay, I got two more days in me. Right.
But the point is like they have
something to aim themselves at. Right.
Is at the beginning we didn't. But even
then, booze wasn't a big deal to me.
It was just what we did.
Like you said,
fast forward to this fall that would
just pass and I realize I'm crashing.
I felt like 52 or something.
You saw something. Oh you,
cause I kind of caught you off.
You were talking about seeing the
program where they show addicted people.
What's that program called?
Intervention interaction.
When I first got wounded in oh seven and
that's when I realized I was addicted
to the pills but not addicted.
Like I need a pill.
It was like my body would just start
reacting and I would be like, oh,
I'm itchy for some reason.
And then that's when I started easing off
and I never took a pill after father's
Day 2011. Uh, but even
that you read the book,
I ended up buying pills from a
guy in an alley once and I went,
what the fuck is it like,
and the system is treating me like
an asshole because I want more pills.
And then they're like, yeah,
if you want more appeals,
you've got to come to the hospital
everyday. You get your dose. I'm like,
I'm not a fucking junkie dog.
I just don't let the dose you're giving
me isn't enough to keep me from feeling
like shit and like, and then a mitigating
my stress with the pills. So maybe,
okay, so go to more therapy and that's
when I started rebuilding in 2011.
So come the fall. I'm still not
on my legs. I, this is 2011,
2011 is when I quit the pills.
Got It.
And that's why I thought
booze wouldn't be a problem.
Cigarettes aren't a problem. Boozes or
problem. You'd feel like problems. I mean,
you'd quit pills, whatever.
It was like, oh, whatever.
When the time comes for you to quit booze,
you'll just quit.
That's when I'm ready. I'll be done
with it. Got It. And, but what I, what,
what happened and if you're a politician,
the most important thing, federal, uh,
state, uh, municipal.
So Canada state would be
provincial budget money.
Money is the big thing that everybody
worries about in private live and
everything else. So when are
we talking about right now?
Sorry, you're already bad.
You're behind on bouncing around a
little bit. I'm just saying in my mind,
2017 wasn't that big a deal as far as
the drinking because I'd kicked all these
other habits and I,
whether it's real or not,
I had an army psychologist once tell me
I had an auntie addictive personality
because I guess like you,
like to me it's like, okay,
well what's going to
help me function better?
What's going to get me to the
next day without too many issues?
And if I want to have a few drinks,
I'm gonna have a few drinks and I can
cause tomorrow morning I don't have to be
anywhere until 9:00 AM anyway.
So whatever,
if I'm a little hung
over when I get there,
I'll have a coffee and a glass of water
or Gatorade and an Advil. Not a big deal.
Fast forward to again,
my daughter's birthday last fall.
Oh daddy can't be there yet cause I'm
still hung over. Right. I got my car,
I and I, and it was when I realized
I'm going through, I was like,
I felt this before because I kept
asking myself, what the fuck?
Why do I keep screwing everything up?
And then the budget's process started.
That's where I was going with this.
And that's where I remembered.
I'm not cause your Jocko, you're not a
private citizen anymore. You know that,
right? What do you mean? Well, if
you fell off Instagram tomorrow,
there's a million people out
there. I'd probably be like, well,
where the fuck is Jocko?
And I was posting less.
I was being less upbeat and what I did
post the few last couple of podcasts,
even going back to the
spring on one of them,
we got loaded and we said it was for fun,
but I like,
I needed a drink myself. Um, and uh,
I'm starting to miss budget and budget
is money. That's what everything runs on.
The city of Ottawa has a three
and a half billion dollar budget.
Why isn't counselor Munich at the budget
meeting for the Community Protective
Services Committee, Community
Protective Services Committee. Oh,
he's not feeling well. His legs are
bugging him. Stuff like whatever.
My staff said, I'm tell it, they're asking
me what's going on boss. And I'm like,
yeah, I just, I need
you to buy me some time.
But that's when the media and
the voter goes, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We get it. You like to write
books and you like to do podcasts,
you'd like to shoot guns and you,
you know you're a dude and we
and we accept you as who you are.
But our four year commitment,
the biggest part of that commitment is
making sure that money is spent properly
and on the things that we want it spent
on and we elected you to be that voice.
Why aren't you at that
meeting and personal private
matters can only get you so
far during like the most important
part of of your job, right?
While either go on medical leave or be
at the meeting is basically what I was
told. Right. Get a doctor's note
or be here. And that's when uh,
I ended up doing that radio interview in
December when it really came to a head
and when I had to really admit
to myself like I'm border,
I think I was in my mind I was
borderline alcoholic I guess.
Um,
but I was,
I was just not able to deal
with that failure in myself.
How much,
how much were you drinking at the peak?
It was a 40 ounce of whatever I get
my hands on sometimes it was like to
remember one time it was
two 26 ounce bottles of Rye,
of crown royal was my brand of choice
and a, if that wasn't around again, Jack,
Dan Lynn, you're drinking, you're getting
done with work and that's it. You know,
at this point I just waking up in
the morning and drinking at work.
Like I was just,
I knew in the morning I couldn't go
and then you feel like shit because you
drank all day. So what do you do
that you go for the hair of the dog?
And that just turns
into a perpetual circle.
And then the wounds I was
talking about earlier,
they're not healing because my body's full
of alcohol. And a friend of mine said,
you know what, my dad used to have that
problem because he drank too much too.
And he would like cut his hand working
on like a woodwork and the shed and it
would be there for like
six, eight, nine months.
And then he'd sober up for a couple
months and then it would go away.
But then he'd fall back and I went,
you're dad the maniac you've told me
stories about. And she was like, yeah.
And I'm like, okay. So this
is really becoming a problem.
So now I'm dealing with the internal
struggle of I'm a complete failure of a
human being. I've met, failed
my kids, I failed the voters,
I failed like friends of mine,
like Jocko and Echo, who, you know,
we expect certain things from each other,
right? Or we think we do. And you could,
you could have a terrible day.
And I would never judge you for it,
but you don't know that until it happens.
Right.
And even if you know that you
still don't want to admit it,
nevermind to Jocko or echo,
how about to yourself? Right.
And again, I'd stopped meditating,
I'd stopped going to my therapist,
I'd stopped going to the gym,
I'd stopped podcasting,
I'd stopped writing really even though,
and then during the book tour in October,
and I know I'm rewinding a little bit,
but I,
the last thing I want to
do is go on the book tour.
But the book is coming out and that's a
commitment that I signed and you know,
you're dealing with all this and I,
and I did the tour in my wheelchair
and everybody's like, oh,
you're doing so much better cause you're
okay with being in the wheelchair.
And I'm like, yeah, cool. Close the hotel
room door and like opened a drink, right.
Have a drink.
So December was the
worst month of my life.
Getting blown up was easy in my opinion,
dealing with this shit.
But what I didn't do in 2007 was actually
deal with the fact that I was blown
up, frankly. I was so
like, yeah, recover, be,
be useful to the regimen, be useful. The
Queen Bee get better for the country. Um,
put prosthetic legs on life as normal
ish. And then now I'm like, okay,
first of all, now, dude, you're
40, uh, second of all your,
you have kids that are now like,
where the f like I would see them and
they'd be like, we miss you. Like,
where have you been? Like, why
aren't you around more? And like you,
you don't live far away. Like
what's your excuse because, oh,
because I'm ashamed of you seeing me
all dealing with the next day of being
drunk and stuff, you know?
And, and it really, it really,
it really became,
I understand now I've,
I've always been sympathetic to
addicts since my oxycotton days,
but now I get how depression
can really make you into
someone not worth saving in your
own mind. And I get, I get it.
And I've, I've never dis, uh,
I've never thought hatefully or anything
of friends that have committed suicide
or have gone down that path of depression
that you just, if you're not in it,
you don't get it. And you go, man,
why can't you just like read a book or
listen to some comedy or not drink today?
Like have, I'll sit with you and
have a water and you're like,
you just don't get it.
And I was doing a lot of this
on my self isolation too,
because you don't want
anyone seeing you like this.
And then the few people that do
hang around are often in the same,
in one of the levels of, of
fuck up of life. Fuck up.
And so,
you know,
I've talked about this before where it
sounds like you're describing exactly.
I talk about how like people get into a
place where they're basically in a storm
right there,
there's a storm all around their head
and no matter which direction they look,
they just see clouds and thunder
and rain and horror. Right.
And everybody that's outside that storm
looks at him and they go, well yeah,
you're in a storm. Just come over
here and you'll be out of the storm.
Just move over here and
you'll be able to storm. Yeah.
Just put down the drink or you know,
you start working out again or whatever.
You just move over here and you'll be out
of the store. Yeah, but, but that person
can't see, they can't see the directions.
Everything around them is a storm.
They don't understand how me coming over
there is like climbing a mountain and
not to give anyone shit but maybe a little
bit of Shit if you know who you are.
Hey Man, uh, one to watch UFC
tonight at my place. Yeah. Cool.
Except hey bro, I'm in a wheelchair.
I can't even get into your front door.
Can you come to my place where I can get
around and take a piss without getting
out of water bottle and you know like
being embarrassed in front of your wife.
Yeah. But you live all the way over there.
Like we've already got plans and shit.
Like, well cool. What about
next weekend? Eh, that Kinda,
that didn't help as well because people
like, they don't like even coming here,
you're like, aw, this is
buddy carry up the stairs. And
I'm like, yeah, I trust you.
But at the same time,
like some of my friends offering to carry
me into their house or like 140 pounds
soaking wet, never been lifted a weight
in their life and nothing against them.
But it's like you want me to trust my
physical safety or you could just come to
my place like, like, and they
don't get it and I don't,
I'm not mad at anyone about it.
It's like a,
it's like that saying like
I don't hate them about it,
but at the same time it's Kinda
like, all right, cool man.
I'll just watch the fight and we can
text and I'll be at my place alone again.
Right. Like, cause I didn't leave my dog.
Isn't that the place where
I'm at right now? Right.
So that all thing just kind
of fell into a big blender.
And in December. Um, how long did that,
so did this, when you got back in your
wheelchair, you gave up the leg? Yeah,
this is me. This is May. So in
May when you get, like I said,
can we went on that long trip, you went
to Albany, you come back from that,
now you're now you're like
dumbed down with my prosthetics.
They're freaking killing me.
Yeah.
And I'm getting in a wheelchair
back in the wheelchair.
Is that sort of like now you're just,
you're not,
you're just gaining momentum
going downhill. I, yeah.
Well that and but that's a crazy thing
is I thought I'm starting to climb up
because I'm like finally admitting I
can't wear my prosthetics cause I would
like walk into council,
which is the big,
like every two weeks you do the big
meeting and that's where all like all
everything you went to the bar and drank
about and then went to the office and
like argued behind the
scenes with each other.
Now you sit down and you
go all those in favor, Aye.
All those against the nay and then
it's passed a resolution passes.
And now it's illegal to eat ice
cream on bank street on Sundays,
which is a bylaw in Ottawa that I'm going
to actually try and get changed by the
way from like 18 hundreds but
the point is that's the big show.
Like if all the other training,
right,
that's the live fire exercise
or that's the actual op, right?
So that's what your work for.
So when I started missing those at the
end of the year when we're pat like the
budget is the thing that
if without budget you have,
you guys just had a government
shutdown over budget. Yup.
That's what you're trying to avoid. And
that's when the media who, you know,
they're doing their job,
but Jody Mitic and a headline gets clicks
and now Jody Mitic the guy everybody
loves, oh he's fucking
up. What's going on here?
One guy even made a video called no show
medic because I'd missed like four or
five meetings, but the meetings
I'd missed were the ones out.
Like you could miss every other meeting
throughout the year and nobody would
give a fine fuck of a rolling donut.
Which is a saying out of a book,
a series of books I love but,
but I miss these three
meetings. Oh No. Oh no man.
Like these are the meetings we really
voted for you to be at where you at?
No show medic.
And this guy is trying to make a name
for himself as a political commentator,
whatever. He's an
asshole. But the point is
to say that shit to my face.
Um,
the point is he's right though.
Where is no show medic and now in Ma,
cause that's what I was in my head
already. Right. And then I'm like, okay.
So I thought if I said personal family
matters or personal health matters,
they get it. They know me, they know
I've dealing with stuff along the way.
But they're like, yeah, we get it man.
But if you don't tell us what's going
on and then we're going to assume you're
just fucking being lazy cause why else?
Why shouldn't we?
And I went,
okay.
And a and a reporter buddy of mine
and I sent you a couple of texts.
That's when I, and I, when you said that
earlier I, my skin went like, you know,
we've got the goosebumps because I
forgot I sent that and I was starting to
think like, okay, I
gotta go back to basics.
I gotta remember who I am and
what I was and my own advice.
And that's why I went,
oh yeah,
I got too comfortable in my pity in the
enemy now is on my left flank and I have
zero defense is on the left flank.
And what do you,
instead of fighting a
shitty losing rear guard,
you turn and you face the fucking,
you face the battle.
So I turned and a reporter friend of mine,
and for the record reporters
are not really friends.
Those friends that you kind of keep at
arm's length and you're always ready to
punch, but you never know,
right? You're not really punched.
But I'm not threatening anyone with
violence. UPC World Weirdos. But the,
he said, he called me on a
personal note and he said, hey man,
here's what's being said in the, in
the, in the media world about you.
And this is what could be going to
headline if you don't say anything soon.
And I, Oh man, okay, well some of
that's true. Some of that's made up,
but that's what you do when you don't
know. And I said, all right, uh,
can I come on your show?
And he's like,
well that's what I was just about to
ask you if you want come on my show.
And that's Evan and we,
and then we went and we talked about it
and he was very kind to me, he's rough.
He's a tough dude. He's a tough a
reporter, but at the same time, very fair.
And he hit me with a few with a
few shifts and I hit him back.
But what I did was I got it all out of
my system because it's basically you feel
like you're holding, nevermind, I'm
keeping a secret from Jocko and echo.
I'm keeping a secret from 40,000 residents
who trusted me to be their counselor.
Then there's all the fans of Jody
Mitic that are out there and all the
supporters who are all amazing and who
all are willing to support you through
the best and the worst of times.
But they can't support you without
anything that they like to them.
I just stopped podcasting for no reason
and I've stopped being positive on
social media. So what, like what did you
just decide? Is this the real Jodie now?
Is that who like were
you faking it before?
Like that's some of the messages I got.
Like all,
obviously you've figured out that
you can still make money and be,
be the asshole you actually are. And I
was like, Oh shit. Like Jesus, it may,
maybe I am that asshole.
But when I did my buddy show a
huge weight went off my shoulders.
I shouldn't say buddy,
but you know,
but the point is that that was the
beginning of me turning into the,
into the fight instead of running.
And I had a couple of setbacks, so,
so hold on. So this show that you
did and you, you said you listen.
I did listen to it, but um, the,
the premise of the show was what you did,
for lack of a better word,
as you took ownership of everything
that was going on. I even laughed a,
I was laughing right before I went
online. I went onto the show. I said,
I'm doing a jock when I'm taking extreme
ownership, extreme ownership. You went,
so you went on there and you said,
look, I'd like a baby. By the way.
Anyone who thinks I'm a tough guy, I been
drinking too much yet. What do you like,
what were the facts that, what were
the things that you took ownership of?
Was that night? That was
the major thing, right?
The booze caused a lot
of the lack of energy,
lack of a t attempted it at attendance
went down because it's one thing to be
buzzed.
It's another thing to be completely
hung over and fucked up and show up for
meeting. Like you, you
didn't know yourself.
I know myself and I know like if
I go in there like this right now,
people will be like, he is
completely fucked. Right.
And I know I'm swearing a lot and
I apologize, but you avoid that.
And then so I said,
okay guys,
well here's why I missed this meeting and
here's why I missed that meeting cause
I've turned to an old friend,
crown royal instead of my,
my therapist and my doctors and my friends
and my family and my supporters and
all the things that made me
able to cope from 2007 to 2017.
So for basically a decade I forgot
about and I left behind like never mind,
never mind the g like stopped the
gym, stop talking to me, therapist,
stopped talking to my kids, stop talking
to my ex, stop talking to my mom,
stopped talking to my
dad, my friends. Again,
I've self isolating and there are times
when I'd want to pick up the phone and
just call like you or rob or um,
or some of my friends at home or some
of my sniper buddies and just be like,
I don't know what to do.
And now you're man Echo, right? Sure.
Imagine trying to make that call. Yeah.
And I'm not saying it's a man problem,
I'm saying it's a
definitely a human problem,
but I'm the guy,
everybody thinks I get told you're the
poster child of success post injury.
And I'm like, in my head I'm
like, I'm a fucking bullshitter.
Like that's how you feel. And
I'm like, whether I am or not,
I've been lucky and I've made a few decent
decisions on for my own accord and I
am where I am through hard work
and discipline and now what?
And now I feel like I'm losing
it all because I have, I
have, I've been faking it.
Was this just a ride that I was on and
now I'm done and I want to get off the
thing. The things that go through
your head now. First of all, I,
I was never suicidal. I had never
thought, never crossed my mind.
I don't know why it just didn't.
But I did have one thought
one day where I went,
I think I understand why some
guys take that path though.
I had a such a day one day
where it was in December and I,
it wasn't like I thought, oh, things
would be better if I was dead.
It was like I just,
I was at such a low moment and I went,
I think I get it.
Why sometimes guys take that path
because it's just like, you know,
like it was just such an extreme
combination of everything from all sides.
And I went, I think I kind of get it now
cause it before, I don't know about you,
but I've, I've tried to figure out why
some of the guys go that route and,
and I just can't. But that moment
I went, oh okay. I kind of get it.
And it was, it wasn't like I
thought solution for myself,
but I just is very quick as it took
about two minutes of in and out.
And it stuck with me though,
because I went,
that's the first time I've ever had
any thought like that. Right. And then,
so my daughter's birthday is late
December and I missed that one too.
And then
New Year's Eve.
And I've already made plans to go and
do an assessment that would tell me how
terrible of an addict I am as a,
as an alcoholic because that's
what you are. You're an addict.
And I'm going to Aa Kinda sorta and
my have a sponsor who's all over me.
He's a great guy and I
won't say his name here,
but he knows who he is and he's
a beautiful human being. Um,
and he's trying to get on top of me.
And Luke is trying to get on top of me
and my mom and my ex and my friends and
they're all trying to just be like, okay
man, like we get it. Now we've heard,
we've heard your call is loud and
clear now. How do we help you?
And then it's trying to like mitigate
that and then Ah, it's, you know,
it's Christmas. I'll have a few drinks. I
know I told the world this, but you know,
I can handle it. I'm not,
I'm not that bad. And then
the next morning you're like,
oh man.
But then New Year's Eve,
I had some company that came
out cause they're like, we
heard you man. We're here.
It's New Year's Eve. Let's hang
out. Let's be floods. Have Fun,
we'll have a few drinks. We're all here
to keep an eye on. You can't get that bad.
We know who you are.
And the next morning it's like I did what?
Because now all the pressure's
on now to get better.
And I was here in radio interviews where
there I was headline news in Ottawa for
a couple of days where they went.
Wow. Real brave of him to say that.
Now how's he going to get better? Guys
are talking about me. I have to retire.
Are resigned from politics.
Uh,
in Canada with the gun laws
as they are a public city,
anyone can call in a threat on
anybody who owns guns, right?
So some gun hating citizen,
and I'm not hating them for this, I'm just
hating them for being a dick. He said,
oh,
I can get a prominent gun owners guns
taken away if I call the police and say,
I think he's a threat to public safety.
And that's all you have to do.
It's completely anonymous,
which is bullshit.
And anyone can do it against
anyone that's a gun owner.
And so now the police call and they say,
listen, we have to do an investigation.
So like, so that actually
happened. So this was,
this was right before New Year's Eve.
So I'm like freaking out.
I am losing my shit. And because I'm
like, I don't know how it works now.
They're very understanding,
but they have to do the check.
They look once the investigation
started real or not, or, um,
substantiated or not, we gotta
go through steps. One does that.
Okay, so they go inspect
the guns. The guns are safe,
the guns are where they're supposed to be.
Everything's locked out,
everything's proper, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah, Dah, Dah. Talk to my family. Nope,
he's never been threatening with them.
That I love the law. And then like,
and then, and then in the new year's eve
rolls around and I have this terrible,
this is the last I,
the last drop of booze I had was new
year's eve and we started with a small
bottle and I drank it all myself
and this past New Year's Eve,
just passengers, he evicts sold
towards today 2022, 23 days ago.
And the next morning,
uh,
I got a little bit of a lowdown about
what I was like and I call him evil Jody.
And he came out once in 2005 after
my first deployment to Afghanistan,
before my second one where I got
wounded and I was bouncing at the time.
And I was, you know, having some
little bit too much fun in life maybe.
But I was also drinking too much
for the wrong reasons at the time.
And a lot of us were because we had
the cane forces, we hadn't dealt with,
you know, combat a lot. Right. Like I
said, and a lot of us were green, uh,
when we went into Afghanistan
the first time. So maybe a lot,
like you said, a fair
number of us, me included,
where maybe choosing the wrong ways.
Um,
I was still meditating and all that,
so mitigated a little bit. But this,
I call them evil Jody, he came out,
my friend, why? One of my buddies who,
uh, still talk to, he's a
police sniper now, but he, he
pulled me aside and he said,
hey man, like I've never ever
seen you act like that ever.
No matter how drunk you were,
what was going on or how angry you were,
who pissed you off? What the fuck
was that about? And I went, oh,
that sounds like grandpa or whatever.
So I locked him in a cage and I used
to joke that, you know, Oh, don't let,
don't let the caveman man out of
his cage. And then, but that night,
so the 25 days ago or whatever it was,
he got out and I didn't
hurt anybody and anything,
anybody said things you
don't shouldn't and I maybe
made actions that you shouldn't. Yeah.
And for me the biggest thing is when you,
you realize that you had no control over
what's happening and how about not even
remembering. Yeah. Well that's
what I'm saying. You don't want,
my dad did all these
things. I said, what to who?
Oh my God. And you're just like
your thing. I, and I called,
so I called one of the people that
was there and I said, I am so sorry.
And he was like, been there, done that
dude. You gotta get your shit together.
I'll be here when you're done,
when you're ready or I'm here tomorrow.
He was such a great guy
about it. And I went, oh,
so the world doesn't hate you for being
a fuck up. And I at that helped too.
We talked about this last night, like
who, when you mitigate, um, crisis,
David Letterman or tiger woods, whoever,
like don't follow the Tiger Woods' book.
Go with David Letterman on it. Explain
what David Letterman did cause I did. So,
yeah, so in, in, in a, in a
nutshell, David Letterman got,
he got caught in an affair on his
wife, David Letterman by the way, is a,
is like a talk show host at night and uh,
yeah,
he's not anymore, but I guess he was
and he was pretty popular at some point.
Yeah. He was already texting. Some
people don't know is a, is a golf player.
So he yeah, if you haven't heard of him
he's like, yeah, he's like half black,
half Thai. And you know, he swung a
golf club pretty good for a minute. Um,
but he got caught cheating on his wife
too. But so David Letterman got, uh, uh,
blackmail letter right before one
of his shows and the guy said,
I know what happened. That it ended
up having an affair or something.
He had had one or he was
having one and it was like,
pay me $40,000 a week for the rest
of my life or this or something.
I'll tell the world. And David
Letterman went, alright, I fucked up.
And he went out. And He, and I
don't remember because I did see it,
but I don't remember exactly how it went.
But basically,
usually they do a monologue, these
guys for their show. And he went,
instead of today's monologue,
I'm gonna look into the camera and I'm
going to say I cheated on my wife and she
knows about it and we're working on it.
And somebody else found out and they
thought they were going to get money from
me. So he looked in the
camera went, fuck you.
The police are coming to your house
right now. And to the rest of you,
I apologize. I'm sorry. Am I have to
my wife? I apologize. And I understand.
If this is a problem for us,
then we will have to deal with it again
because of who I am. It's world news.
And does he? He owned
it. He owned all of it.
And uh, the other day he
interviewed this guy named Obama.
You might've heard of him on his
new show on Netflix called, uh,
I forget what the next guest or
something. And he was on, he's, he,
he's still seen as a good dude.
Right. Cause he own it. Any,
any worked through it and he,
and he didn't not talk about it.
And then there's what tiger woods
did, which is runaway hide, uh,
not admit anything.
And he,
tiger woods went through four or five
years of just complete chaos in his life
before he finally even, I think now
he still places in the bottom 50.
I think he's at the PGA.
He still plays,
but he probably just plays
to pay the bills now.
He was worth $1 billion at one point and
he lost it all because of not owning a
fuckup.
You'd probably still would have lost a
lot of it because his wife took half.
But regardless, sponsors dropped
him. He himself as a human being,
couldn't look himself in the
mirror, I'm sure. Right. And
Blah, blah, blah. So I said,
okay, well this is my tiger
woods or David Letterman moment,
like going on the radio. I thought,
was it, now we're two weeks later,
whatever it was. Yeah. Like two
weeks later. And I'm like, well,
either I never drink again or I continue
down the path of bullshitting myself
into saying, well, I'll just get
better when I'm ready. And, uh,
this journey I've been on for
since I left, uh, what did I leave?
I forget Jan,
18 or 19.
I left Ottawa and I've just been driving.
I've,
I wanted to drive route 66
since I was a teenager. And, uh,
you know, I talked to the kids, I
talked to Atlanta, I talked to my mom,
I talk to everybody
that matter and I said,
I'll be back first city council is
January 31st after our Christmas break
anyway.
And I said I'll be back.
I'm going to go visit some people that
are going to look me in the eye and tell
me if I'm full of shit or not. You
guys be in some of them. And, uh,
when I get back, I'm going to my
therapist. I already have an appointment.
My, uh, my doctor's for my legs,
cause I'm going back to basic training
to learn how to use prosthetics again.
So I don't go through those issues again.
I'm gonna talk about my addiction issues.
I'm going to talk about why I'm not.
I'm going back to the gym.
I have a diet plan already have
a trainer waiting. Um, I'm,
I'm going back to the base.
I'm back.
I'm in basic training to be a
human being again. And I, I was,
I was laughing this morning listening
to your show about the basic training at
Marine Corps base in Parris Island
because I was like, fuck man, I just,
I keep doing this every
three or four years.
I got to go back and relearn what it's
like to be Jody Mitic because I am
evolving.
B,
I had to evolve beyond the soldier and
then I had to print it a citizen and then
out. Now I'm a turning into
something else. I think, uh,
because I had a plan until I was 44 I
thought at 25 years in the army or 28th
was 27 years, retire, become a contractor,
teach shooting for the rest of my life
and just be that grumpy old guy that,
you know. Well, if you want to know about
shooting, you talked to that guy. Be Good,
decent money, right? I didn't want
to get rich. I just wanted to have,
pay my bills and hang out with my,
my dream retirement was going to be to
hurt Alpacas around on my horse with my
rifle, shoot coyotes and, and listen
to like gangster rap and read books.
Like that was it. That was
what I wanted to do. But,
but life has a funny way of pointing you
in directions that maybe you need to go
in there. You didn't
know you had to go. And
I'm back on the Jocko podcast,
spilling my whole life and
my soul out for everybody.
And I hope somebody to learn this.
If we keep one troop from like,
listen, I have, even if you're on the
road where you know you're fucking up,
pull over, call in air
support, like Jocko said,
like you got,
we have so many resources we
don't know about. And uh, you
know, we all, uh, I'm the,
I'm the lone wolf. Well, even
the lone wolf runs in a pack.
And I think that that's how I've, I've
thought like, you know, the soft guys,
you know, we're all Alphas
but we're in teams, you know,
and I rolled in a team of three hardcore
guys. There's me and my boys and,
but we at the same time I knew I had
artillery support, I had air cover,
I had this,
I had another sniper team covering the
flank over there and Ricky platoon over
there and you're never alone.
And even last night, like I,
I felt bad.
I sh I'm still in a tee shirt.
I drove in all day from the tee shirt I
wore the day before and he showed doc,
I've never seen Jocko dressed
up and I'm like, Oh shit,
Jocko is like in a button down
shirt and he's wearing shoes.
Let's not get crazy.
I had on a pair of jeans,
van's a tee shirt and a flannel shirt
that's, you were dressed up, dressed up.
But I'm like, technically I'm like,
I'm like, okay. So I haven't seen it.
Seen you in two years ish,
give or take a few months we've talked,
but it's not like we've been on the
phone for hours and been like, hey bro,
what's going now? Like, you
know, you were busy dudes.
We kept in touch the way guys I guess
do. But we sat down and I'm like, okay,
do I eat dinner and then
tell him tomorrow or,
and I just basically threw up all over
you and you and you were awesome and I
love you for it and I appreciate it.
But I needed that hour of just talking
about myself and I felt bad about it
because I'm like, I haven't even
asked him how his kids are. You have,
I have friends that'll do,
you were willing to do that.
And I've done that for hundreds of guys.
But then when it's you doing the talking
man, it's tough and I get it now.
I get it now more than anything. So
guys, you need, you gotta pull over,
you gotta like you just gotta take a knee
and let somebody else take point for a
bit. And that's just the way
it is. You know, all your set,
you said you kind of understand
when people feel suicidal,
you know when you said that,
no,
I know and I've said that a
bunch of times since it happened,
but what's your question? Sorry.
Let me like, do you, do you,
cause I think about that too sometimes
where that's the only time that we were
at that thought. I don't think about
me. I'm thinking like other people,
like what does it take to be like,
you know what I'm going to in my life.
My question is, do you think that
it's like that feeling is like,
it's almost like this immense
boredom with the, you know,
how like you just don't have,
it's not like this pain that I got to end.
It's more that like there's
really no reason for me to,
it's like you're going up this
hill but the hill isn't that steep,
but it's just so wrong. Yeah. You know, I
think that's part of it. Yeah. Like it's,
it's like from what I've read,
the few suicide notes that I've
seen when you know, when you find,
like we had one, uh, I don't know if I
talked about it on the show last time we,
I was teaching on a sniper
course and one of the guys,
I was talking to him at one moment about
what we're going to do Saturday cause
they're all guys you work
with, right? It's kind of like,
I'm sure it's the same as the seals.
So a lot of them that come on to sniper
course anywhere guys you've picked out
of the platoons and then you know,
even if they pass,
you still have a meeting where you go,
okay,
do we really want to work with echo guys?
Like I know we gave him the badge,
but are we going to let them
into the teams? And then,
so this is one of the guys sold,
you know,
I'm getting to know him a little bit more.
He's from the other battalion and a,
yeah, cool man. I know this girl in town
and this and that and okay, right on.
And 20 minutes later, we're like, where
the fuck did he go? We're doing roll call.
Where the fuck is he? And we found
him hanging from one of the, you know,
the pavilions are out in the training
area, forget shade during lectures.
So he was out there and we find this
letter on his pillow and I'm reading and
it's about they, they feel like they're
in this pain that's never ending. Yeah.
And I don't think it's boredom.
I think it's just this,
it's The no light at the
end of the tunnel feeling.
Yeah. Yeah. As you were
asking that question, um,
that the word I wrote down was,
was cause we've been talking about,
or we've heard from it from the
last couple podcasts that we did,
and it's the same thing you just said.
It's hope.
So when you don't have any
hope that this is going to end,
when you don't see any light at the
end of the tunnel. And like I said,
when you're, when you're stuck in
this storm and everywhere you look,
you don't see the light at the end of the
time, you don't see that the cloud end,
somewhere in the book thundering
lightning will subside.
You just are in a storm no matter where
you look. There's a storm and they say,
you know, if there's no hope
of getting out of this storm.
And I think that's where,
that's where they started having those.
Luckily though, when it, when
the thought entered my mind,
like I get it and what I,
again,
I never thought of suicide, but I had the
thought go through my brain where I go,
I get why some people might
see this as an option.
Cause I did see like, cause I'm texting
him, I'm texting rob, I'm texting. Uh,
you know, my, my buddies in the cans
off. Um, uh, at my regimental friends,
my mom, my dad, my brother,
most of the people that should be aware
there's a problem. We're aware. Yeah.
So I still had lots of light coming in,
but it was my, now it's your choice.
Are you going to go towards it or are
you gonna stay floating where you are,
I guess is a like are you going to reach
for the line or are you going
to sit there and be like, Eh,
it's just at an arm's reach. Yeah, I know.
I talk about detachment all the time
and this is like another situation where
obviously when you're,
when you're
wrapped up in those kinds of
emotions, right? You, you,
you can't see anything else.
Somebody that's outside, they're perfectly
clear, can help guide you out of that.
Even though it's going to be hard.
And there's things that knock,
understand and all that,
but they can at least they know that
they're outside that and they can see it
just like on the battlefield. Somebody
that's at elevation, you know,
you get getting, rebuilding
her position. Yeah. Some guys
go left, go, left, go left,
go right. And you're like, fuck. Yeah. So
if you can reach out to somebody that can,
that has a little bit better,
uh, altitude on the battlefield,
but you're in then end. If you can
reach out to them, say, hey man,
I can't see what's going on,
and all I see is darkness point me in
the right direction and they're going to
tell you some dumb shit like, hey, okay,
let's get you to a doctor.
Let's get you stopped drinking.
Let's get you in the gym again.
They're gonna tell you some stuff.
That sounds stupid. It sounds
well, it sounds way too easy. Yeah,
it sounds way too easy.
You think it's that easy fro a fuck.
But you know what I what I like
what you said is you're like, man,
I keep having to go back to bootcamp.
Yeah. And it's like, that's really,
if you think about what bootcamp is,
what is bootcamp? They're like, okay,
put your shoes on like this. Make
your bed like that. Eat this food,
do this workout. That's what they do. They
get you on the program that Lee, it's,
it's at least a success and it,
and it leads to having your
life somewhat sorted out.
And once you get that, then you
look around and you go, okay,
now these bigger problems. I, if
I can control these little things,
I can control this,
this thing that's a little bit bigger,
and if I can control that, I control
this thing that's a little bit bigger.
If I can control that, I control this
other thing that's a little bit bigger.
But when you're not,
you know,
it's the same thing I talked about all
the time with the sh the Chechens and the
Russians not,
you know,
failing on that first war and it all
started when they stopped shaving all at
the same thing with your personal life,
when you,
when you disregard these,
these fundamental things that
you would do in bootcamp. Yeah.
When you start letting them go,
well then if the little things fall apart,
then the bigger things fall apart.
But contrary to that,
when you put the little things together,
you can start putting the bigger things
together and have you're doing right now,
podcasts I've talked about, what did I
stopped doing? I stopped, oh well fuck,
I'm gonna eat pizza tonight and sit my
prescribed diet that I've done for years
and it makes me feel good and keeps me
in good shape because fuck it today.
And then the next day it's
like, well, I did it yesterday.
I'm going to have cocoa
puffs for breakfast.
And it was just a downward spiral of,
ah, I don't need to go see my therapist.
He's all the way on the other 10 is town.
And I know my life sucks right now.
Don't want somebody to tell me that
my life sucks are, you know, hey,
what do you talk about with a therapist?
What do they talk about?
What do you do there? So I'm
assuming you've never know, uh,
honestly,
like you just bounce life off them.
Or what I'm saying is if you
got a guy that's listening
right now, yeah. That's like, oh, is
it embarrassing? Not even embarrassing.
If you've got a guy that's listening
right now that's going, well,
what the hell would a therapist tell
me? Why would I not just, you know,
write in a journal or, or do something
like that? Do that too. Okay.
I write in a journal, which I
again, which I stopped doing again.
The writing in the journal is like
yourself check cause I go back,
I was reading through my journal, I kept
a journal throughout the year, Kinda,
but you know,
not as often as you should.
And I was reading through it and I'm
like, wow, I'm even bullshitting myself.
And this,
my last therapy session,
which is right before the
downward angle started,
um, he said a few things to
me that needed to be said.
And I kind of took it to heart. Like I
was like, Oh shit. But basically he said,
you're putting a lot of work into
be in Jody medic. And I was like,
fuck you man. You don't even
know. You don't even know.
But to like listen, like this is over
a year ago. And right now I'm like,
I'm still like, ouch, that
hurt. But he was right.
And it took me this whole time to get
to the point where I'm leveling off now.
But therapy is, you know, um,
I think I said this to you last night,
it's like tiger woods, tiger woods,
bad example on how to mitigate crisis
but had a golf coach his whole career.
And guess when he started sucking,
when he stopped seeing his golf coach.
No one is an expert on life.
Um,
I didn't have PTSD when I got wounded.
I was cleared to different therapists and
a psychiatrist both said clear to PTSD,
massive depression, which is normal
for losing even a loved one. Right.
And when they you, when you lose a limb
they say it's like losing a loved one.
So two loved ones died when
it, but whatever, whatever.
But PTSD can come back. We in Canada
we call it operational stress injury,
which I was diagnosed with,
which is like an injury.
So if you sprain your ankle or
break your ankle, it's an injury.
One heals differently from the other right
left alone. They both lead to failure.
Your ankle will completely deteriorate
and fall off and have to be cut out of
the body or replaced if you
don't treat it, if you're,
um, I dunno, what do you guys
call the Humvee or what do
you call it? Truck. Yeah,
Humvee. Humvee. Palmer. If
you're a hammer blows and axle,
do you yell at it and tell, just toughen
up and go have a fucking drink? No,
you send it in for fucking maintenance.
Yeah.
And I used to say this
to troops all the time.
I'll say it again and I've said it before.
I've said this to colonels and generals
like, Dude, man, if you need maintenance,
go and go to the fucking maintenance shop.
Which is in our case,
the fucking mind guy. I had a talk
with the chief of defense staff,
which is our not sect of a chief of staff,
of the chairman of the joint chiefs.
Yeah. And we were talking about combat
units and I said, well, you know,
and we were both getting on the floss
philosophy, nickel situs things. Um,
Samurai used to meditate and practice
and they do practice calligraphy to
perfect it.
And the tea ain't a warrior.
Monks of Europe would
meditate or pray and fast.
Um,
the Mongolian hoards even had their
ceremonies where they purge the demons and
let it, uh, what do our modern soldiers
do? There's no self reflection.
There's no meditation. There's no, we got
to start from basic training. I've said,
and I don't know if I said this on the
last podcast, if I did, I apologize.
I forgot my own advice again.
What's rice?
Rice for your body. Oh, rest.
Ice Compression.
Elevation.
That's taught to you the first day
of basic training because you're on,
I remembered it. Ah, right.
But that's your vehicle, right?
And your vehicle is your body
that gets you into combat,
which is where the unit needs you,
which is where your country wants you.
What's race for the mind?
And this is where we all as a society
have to go back and think about these
things like Jujitsu. Jujitsu
is, it is, it is surfing.
But this is my point.
So when you go to a therapist,
if you have no Jujitsu in your life,
you don't have surfing,
you don't have calligraphy,
you don't know how to meditate.
This could be the beginning of you
learning how to be of the beginning of
learning rice for your mind. And that's
how I look at it. But even still,
I know enough about medicine that I can
take care of myself for the most part
without going to the doctor.
But guess what now and then I hit
something and I go, fuck, I need a doctor.
So therapy doesn't mean you have to
go every week on order like clockwork,
but have someone that you're,
that's your therapist or
your psychiatrist or whoever,
whatever level you need or you qualify
for and your benefits and that doesn't
mean you go see them all the time.
I had a guy that I saw when I had to,
but a lot of it is up to you to the
individual is still a big part of this.
I as an individual,
this is where it hit me really hard.
And when you heard the emotion in my
voice on the radio that day I stopped even
paying attention to myself and I
as an individual failed myself,
my friends, Mike, Sorry, myself, my
family. So my daughters, my aunts, my mom,
my dad, everyone who loves me for
who I am, no matter what I do.
And then I failed everyone around
me that, um, my friends, you guys,
and this is how you feel because
I didn't as an individual,
take ownership of the problem.
So now I am and I'm going back to
therapy and born back to the gym.
I'm back on my diet. I know
I don't look it, but hey,
I'm on the road and you know those little
powdered donuts in the little thing
with a coffee while you're
driving. Delicious. Outstanding.
You're talking about the chocolate
covered ones are the those ones too.
I found those ones at a gas station and
like Texas somewhere and they are gone.
That's a pro. We don't have those things
in Canada. They have them in America,
but Dunkin donut donuts might
be better than Tim Hortons.
I'm going to go ahead and
say they're better. Oh,
Danny Canadian then wants to fight me.
Tim Morton's is owned by a Brazilian
company now. So whatever the point is, um,
I'm getting back to that life that led me,
that kept me in check because getting
your legs blown off as a rough go.
And I'll tell you that right now, but
it's not impossible. But like any injury,
I have a spot in my back,
like mid back,
just below the shoulder blades that I hurt
when I was 14 and I felt didn't basic,
I felt that throughout my whole career.
But you work on the muscles around it
and you learn to mitigate its impact on
your daily life.
Mental injuries are the same.
And I can tell you I was cleared of Ptsd,
which is like the extreme mental injury.
But I did have a mental
injury and I forgot that.
And then I had physical injuries on
top of it that I basically ignored.
You know, like even the mayor of
Ottawa, he'd be like, hey Jody a,
your Olympian today,
what's going on?
I didn't think you're gonna
make it to this event.
This is before the wheels fell off
I go, yeah, Mary, uh, you know,
I was feeling a little pain and I
know I don't have to be here today,
but then I remembered, yeah, I'm not
a pussy, so I'm here. And he'd laugh.
They're like, oh, Jody, you're
unique collocation, that's for sure.
But what I'm saying is like,
I'm too stupid to stay home tonight so
that tomorrow morning I can feel better
and go to the gym and play with my
kids like that. You know what I mean?
Like it's too, too, too
tough to be that dumb.
A lot of this clearly is ego.
Oh Bro, you go as a motherfucker.
And it's funny because,
and I talk about this all the time,
but like obviously you wouldn't be who
you were and have done what you've done
if you didn't have an ego that drove you,
that made you want to be the, I mean,
why would anyone subject themselves
to going to sniper school of, yeah,
it sounds like a cool job. It's, it's
a shitty job at socks. It's hard to do,
but guess what? Your Ego, you're like, I
want to do that. I want to do the best.
Donny Walberg shows you the sexiest part
of the job, which is shoot bad guys,
which is like so rare by the way.
Like yeah,
the rest of the job saw so,
so you wouldn't have done,
I mean that the books, the politicians,
the pocket, everything that you've done,
there's, there's some element
of ego that drives it.
Obviously you want to serve and it will,
you wouldn't be if it was just pure ego,
you wouldn't be able to do it either
because you have to have the will to serve
and a desire to serve your
country and your brothers in arms.
So that's true too.
But to take it to the next level,
you've got to have some
ego driving and then what?
That's that thing that can drive you to
success can also drag you down when you
start saying, I can do anything. I can
get through this. I can get through this.
I don't need any help.
I can keep on this path.
I can quit drinking whenever I want. Those
are all things that your, your, your,
your,
your ego is your
biggest enemy, but you are your
own biggest critic as well.
Jocko, I'm sure you have these
thoughts like any other human being.
Like if I fail anyone today,
the person I don't want to fail is
myself because you have an expectation of
yourself. And I know, I know enough
about you and I've, you know,
we are the enough of the same guy.
As much as we are different that the
biggest person I'm trying to live up to
expectations or my own. So when you
get up at 4:00 AM every day again,
God dammit. I wish I could, but I'm
not built that Bro. I like to sleep.
I don't have to, if I don't want to do
anyway. But they'd see, listen, right now,
like I can get up at three 30 the fuck
wanted to. Okay. I just don't want to,
I don't have to. I can get all my shit
done in eight hours. Cake Jocko. Uh,
but your ego is the one that goes,
I can do that.
And then your critic is the one
that goes and he can't bitch.
And if you fail,
the first critic that's they're looking
at is the one when you look in the
mirror and you go, I would do
it, man. I would fucking do.
I would look in the mirror. I stopped
like the like, cause you know I like,
I keep a bit of a beard.
Most Times my beard got big and then it
started growing in here and that's when
you know something's up with somebody
when the group, no, I'm serious right now.
I know. That's like, cause I
wouldn't look in the mirror. Yeah,
because when I looked in the
mirror, I, I saw somebody who went,
you drank last night again, didn't
you? Fucking loser. Good job. Yeah.
Why don't you shower and go and work.
So this,
this started coming in because even if
I looked in the mirror is just enough to
be okay. I'm not a complete mess.
Run out the door. My hair grew.
It's, it's, it's weird
man. I can, I'm going,
I'm trying to write this down because I,
even if it doesn't come out
for anybody but myself, it's,
yeah,
I didn't go through with the legs losing
the legs and I did go through losing my
legs again, but whole other thing,
bunch of stuff was happening,
like realizing,
I know I said to soldier is dead,
but maybe I didn't really realize and
I had all these people looking up to me
and also turning to me to have,
okay,
hey my buddy's in trouble.
Go talk to Jodi,
this guys that she's in trouble like and
you're taking on all this other stuff.
And honestly man self, I
don't know what they call it.
Self care I think is what they call it.
Self care is your first priority.
Self-Aid we call it self self.
But that's like your first
person you got to take care of.
And luckily my daughters are
so awesome that, you know,
I talked to them on the trip every day
and like you okay when you get back. Yeah,
we'll, we'll, we'll kick it off
right where we left it off. But
they're the first ones that are going
to forgive you if you asked for it.
And so I've asked my daughters, I told
him daddy's going through some stuff.
Right. You've noticed they're both
like, yeah, cause kids don't get,
you don't give a shit echo.
You've got kids, right? Yes. Yeah.
How many you got again to their,
their first ones going to tell you when
they were the first ones to tell me like,
hey, how come you're not coming around
as much as you said you would like.
God dammit. Daddy's really busy. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. You've always been busy.
We want to go to the park.
Um, but yeah, man, I'm on,
I'm just trying to rebuild everything and,
and stay,
stay on the finally I think,
I hope when I'm 50 I'm not going through
something again because by then I'm
just going to be tooled to want to
deal with Shit, you know? I'm like,
I'm not saying that's old,
I'm just saying like,
you should have your shit together
by the time you're 50 I think.
Or maybe I will, but at least I'll have
these lessons learned over the last,
since 2007 or so.
You're trying to write these down.
You mean you're writing down what
you're going through right now?
I'm writing it down and also because I am
in the position I'm in, right? You know,
we're, we're authors now out of
anything else, like we talked,
we talked about this last night,
doesn't make us artists,
but Kinda does write writing is an art.
Um,
but people, if people can learn
from what I'm going through,
and I know others have
written books and done the,
gone through the exact same thing,
but we all have a unique way of presenting
things. Maybe I turn it into a lesson,
maybe I turn it into something I read.
Like I've read your book
four times since it came out.
I'm rereading Tim Ferriss's book again,
a four hour work week because that's the
direction of life that I would like to
go in politics or not
like doing it your way,
but in a way that's smarter, not
harder. And in the army, right?
We learn there's the smart way.
There's the hard way.
And then there's the
army way or in the navy,
I'm sure it's the same and
sometimes none of them make sense,
but you get it done. But I, you know,
I want to spend more time on myself,
my kids, my loved ones,
my friends. And I think,
and I said,
it sounds a little conceited and a
little bit egotistical and a little bit
selfish, but I've realized
that getting my legs blown off,
maybe I've earned the right to just do it,
kind of what I want a little bit
more than I did in the last 10 years.
And I want to hang out with my friends,
do something constructive for society
still. But if I want to go shoot,
I want to go shoot. If I want to
drive my car across America long,
I just want to do that.
And I think I've earned the right to have
a little bit of flexibility in life to
just throw my kids in the car and go,
well, I actually know you've earned that.
Right. And, uh, I told you that
the first day I met you whenever,
when you were talking about what you're
doing. And I was like, man, you're,
you're doing way more than I'd
be doing. You know, I'd be,
I'd be spending a lot of times my kids,
but you know,
you have goals and aspirations and,
and you've achieved those, you know,
and you've done a great job up there
and, and so that's good. You know,
it's awesome to see. And if that changed
directions and now you can focus on,
you know, taking care of your family,
taking care of yourself, which yeah.
Have you earned it? How? Yeah,
you've earned it, man. Well,
I think what we always forget and what
I forgot and I've continuously have to
remind myself is I'm the beginning
and the end of everything in my world.
And that sounds like a self, uh, what do
you call itself? Self fulfilling prophecy?
No, no, no, no. Self involved.
A little too self involved.
But if I'm not up and ready to go at 8:00
AM my kids don't get to school on time.
And if my kids are late,
their teacher's mad at them and then it's
a snowball in their life. If I'm late,
they wonder where I am. If, if I'm not at
the office, my staff has to tell someone,
hey, where's counselor medic? Uh, he's not
here right now. Where is he? I don't know.
Or they may have to make
them a bullshit excuse.
And even if you tell them your job is
to lie for your boss, no, no, it's not.
Your job is be on to work on time Jody.
So self care and self help
and all that stuff is,
and taking care of yourself
is the beginning of taking
care of everyone that you
feel you have a duty to.
Yeah.
And that's ultimately what I wanted to
talk about here and what I want. You know,
so you know,
when I,
when I bust your balls about getting
up at three 30 in the morning,
that's what Jocko does to make sure that
everything in Jockos life falls into
place for those. You have four kids, Bro.
I don't know how you
keep up with them all.
I only have two and I can barely
do it. And, and so what I'm saying,
when I go back to my,
having my legs blown off,
earns me the right to be
a little bit selfish about
what I do with my time. Well,
I'm going to be selfish and
take care of myself more,
which I haven't for a decade.
Well, I would expand that to,
to really to everybody.
I'm going to tell you what I mean.
You owe it to yourself, everybody,
whether you've been wounded or not, right.
Wherever you are in life,
because the fact of what you just said,
you got to remember this.
If you don't take care of yourself,
you can't take care of the
other people around. Right? And,
and so you have to take care of yourself.
My simple thing,
and my wife knows this about me,
like if I don't work out, I'm,
I'm not. Uh, I'm not, I'm not, I'm
not the same person right now. Good.
[inaudible] you know, but, but really,
if I'm not taking care of my health,
then everything else kind of
starts falling apart. And so yeah,
you've got to take care of yourself.
And if you don't take care of yourself,
then you can't take care of
the people that you care about.
And so that's the duty really.
And that's what I wanted to talk about
a little bit today and what I was saying
before about if you're feeling it
pull over and that's the thing,
like you can't expect anything
of anyone else if you can't,
if you can't show up at work on time,
like why should you,
your staff and if you don't
take care of yourself then,
then why should you expect to
take care of anyone else. And
we all have support, you know, and
I'm, I'm, I know him, I don't know,
I'm hammering this little
too hard, but dude, I'm, I'm,
I'm learning a hard lesson
here and I'm trying to avoid,
we all I think have to learn
it, but there's like, there's,
you can learn it harder than others and
I think I'm learning it the really hard
way because I am a public person,
like,
like a private in a,
in Canada we call them blogging.
Blogging is like Smith in the army so
if blogging is having a rough time,
he doesn't have to go on
the radio until the world.
He doesn't have to go on the
Jocko podcast and tell the world,
but he has to tell somebody and
that's the biggest thing you think.
You think it's scary to go to a therapist
who is a trained professional like
think of a therapist like going to the
rifle range and learning from the masters
sniper.
That's what you're doing.
You're going to learn how to
shoot except for for your mind,
would you not go to the range to learn
from a master sniper if you want to be a
better shot,
of course you fucking would.
I F I'm a master sniper and I'd go to
the range and learn from Masters Navy
right now. That's what a therapist or
psychiatrist or psychologist or counselor,
any of them are professionals
in the mental game of life.
Now I'm not saying all are equal as well.
If you don't like one,
fire him and get a different one,
but start there and start looking for the
help that's available and don't put it
all on yourself. And again, if you think
that's embarrassing, going to a stranger,
which is actually pretty easy when
you actually get in the room and start
talking,
you find you might,
they might have told you to shut
up because the hours up. Um,
try going on the radio or
the Jocko podcast or writing
a book like a, you know,
I put out a lot of my warts in that book
too and I'm still learning and I've got
all these resources so you know, it's not,
it's not, it's not. No one's too proud.
No one's too tough.
And I'm about done like talking.
Let's talk about something
fun right now bro.
No, it's all good man. I
think you know I'm, I'm,
as we were talking and I didn't,
I didn't know if we were gonna do a
podcast or not when you came down here.
I didn't know if you want
to talk about in this stuff,
we're just going to hang out.
I appreciate this cause the whole drive,
I've been thinking and talking to
myself and listening to other podcasts,
I'm like,
I needed to do this.
Yeah, and really like what
you're saying is going to,
it's obviously it's going to help people,
especially the idea,
and I'm glad you talked about this a
little bit, you kind of food in there,
but like looking at
yourself in the mirror,
looking at yourself in the mirror and
saying to yourself, you know what?
I need some fire support here.
I'm going to reach out and I'm going to
get it from some people and there's not
a damn thing in the world in
the world wrong with that.
And that's how you sort of,
that was the thing.
That was the thing that made
you go, okay, I need help.
I'm gonna go make this happen.
And so it may be that can help some
other people that aren't feeling too good
right now. Go look in the mirror and admit
to yourself, you've got some problems.
Maybe the problems are a
little bit bigger than you.
We've been in combat situations
that were bigger than us.
You have to call in fire support.
There's nothing wrong with it.
There's no shame in it.
Go make it happen.
Yeah. And uh, and take care
of yourself. Take ownership.
Extreme ownership. I like
the way you think. Ah, know.
Um, yeah, I think that's a good place,
man. I think that's a good place to chill.
If we want to talk about something
different, we can do that really easily.
All we do is we just ask echo to talk
for a little bit. Yeah. Getting some,
some philosophy stuff. Charles.
Yes. You, uh, you know,
we want to talk about something good.
Can you talk about something good?
Like maybe how to support ourselves and
if someone wants maybe how someone could
support this podcast if they want,
which we should,
yeah. Juggle Krill oil and
joint warfare. Here's the thing.
You know how like my joints have
been hurting me lately. Yeah.
And sometimes you can be to some joint
warfare for sure. Yeah. It helps.
Not In a non drug fair far
pharmaceutical way. It's good. Yeah.
It's interesting.
But it does work,
especially if you're getting
physical and whatnot.
General joint disintegration
or degeneration. Degeneration,
not disintegration. Yeah, I don't,
I don't know how much you would tell with
this integration. Nonetheless, Jocko.
Some supplements, they're good
supplements. Therefore your joints.
One is Krill oil. Super Krill
oil. The other one's called joint.
Where for glucosomine could
Jordan. Yes. Curcumin and curcumin.
Desperate like cartilage. It's
all right. It's joint war. No,
cause you know how like when your
meniscus or like your elbow like big words
just talk about, I'm telling you this
is, this is the truth, the real deal.
So if I take this,
the knee I tweaked the other night,
this will help it with the meniscus
around my kneecap. Yes. The, the,
the joint warfare will
I'm into it. Yeah. Fully.
Also what we kind of talked about earlier,
Jocko discipline preworkout
we call it pre workout,
but it's a pretty mission
cause as cognitive enhancers.
Pretty mission. I love this.
Jodi's checking it out, fired
up about it nonetheless.
That's good. That's good for anything
you're about to do. So we say pre workout,
it can be pre study, pre
exam, pretest, three,
uh, three podcasts, podcast, whatever
you, whatever you like. It's good.
Unless you can get two scoops. Don't
be a pussy. Take two scoops guys.
I come on led. What are we saying here?
Sorry. Sorry. No, not at all. I had,
I had a real long right.
The other night of of work.
Did you take them and I took three. Yeah.
Yeah. What do you normally take? Two.
Two. So what do you, what are
you weighing in now to 20 no,
probably two 32 32 scoops
is enough for you? Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. So I'll
stick to two scoops for now. Yeah.
But I might ramp it up to four
if I really have to be careful.
Make sure you have something
to do like a project.
Like don't just take like writing a
bucket. Yeah. That's due to right. No,
that's a great time. Yeah. If you have
to. Right. And then do you find it,
does it make you jittery? No,
no, no. [inaudible] smooth.
But you got the energy.
It's got caffeine is pretty low. Caffeine
is very low. The same caffeine is Jocko.
White tea is the same amount, so per
scoop. So you'll get double that.
But it's not.
It's 15 milligrams,
so it's meant to not make you all jittery
because you can't, that's not good.
Everything else I'm reading in here and
what little I do know about nutrition.
This is all stuff for focus and
longterm, like energy release. Yes.
The only thing missing that I, I don't,
I don't know. Science is B vitamin.
Is that in there already?
Missing it. That's what I know.
So turning 40 means I have to wear
glasses now too, by the way. Perfect.
I know what to smaller,
my perfect just in case sniper vision
I think is good for long distance,
but now I'm like my dad. I'm like,
yeah, you got to find the sweet spot.
That's what it is in there,
right?
Because your eyes can't like f l
two S or whatever. I'll be taking,
can I have a case? You can have that
right. The street. I'll just keep,
I'll just keep this right here.
Actually. That's good. And surprisingly,
tastes good.
You wouldn't expect doctors to be like
[inaudible] very hyper about making
things taste tastes like crap.
Then my life is hard.
Food should be tasty. Yeah. I dig it
and I understand that. But you would,
why chalk then you can drink.
So you're saying it's out of character
for me to watch them in line.
I think that's the dichotomy of you,
cause I heard that before.
Even like with how you said you don't
drink coffee, you're like, I just,
I don't like the taste of coffee. Why
would I drink? I'm like, oh, all right.
You don't like there's taste not rough.
You don't like the taste.
You don't like the taste. Right.
And I made fun of when I did drink,
my friends who drink beer because that's
Canadian is to drink beer and I'm like,
beer tastes like shit. I'll drink
cider. Ooh, the apple juice. I'm like,
it's got more alcohol than beer bitch.
Like it's what,
what do you like if he doesn't
like coffee? He likes white tee.
I think white t sucks, but
I'm not Jocko, we got this,
I'm making this protein powder right
now and like criteria number one was you
had has to be good protein and all that.
But the strong second criteria was
it's got to tastes so damn good.
Which I forget you're drinking protein.
I the first sample tasted really good.
Like I was shocked at how good the first
substrate. We tweaked it a little bit.
The second sample came back. It tastes
even better. I mean, one, hang on,
how much sugar we talking,
there's no sugar. Oh No,
there's no guy that used to be
the trick. Just proteins. So good,
but it's 30 grams of sugar,
no sugar,
and then the F we've got
one more coming back,
but the second iteration of it
tastes delicious and equity.
The samples left no echoes yesterday.
He's like, he's like, well, you know,
I don't never really liked
protein powder, and I'm like, Bro,
this has nothing to do with you
wanting to drink protein powder.
You'll be drinking this like
you want a drink. It'd be like,
it'd be like chocolate milk. It's so good.
Yes. Yeah, so we'll see about that one.
That one.
It's where can you get all this Shit Echo?
The proof is going to be
in the pudding as they say,
or Jim [inaudible] dot com
that's where you get it.
also@originmain.com you can get you,
we'll get Keith rash guards
is for Jujitsu by the way.
Oh yes sir. Made in America.
I know Jody is from Canada.
Better than made in somewhere else. Yeah,
I know a lot of us have a candidate.
We don't have time to make geese
and stuff like make it in America.
There's 10 times more people down here.
Yeah,
I dig it and all this stuff on there.
It's made in America. That's good. Yep.
Go there.
See if you want something,
get something good way to
support also fitness gear.
Jocko got a new kettle bell that
is heavier than mine. Does it?
His head is it, is it, is it your
little head that you got on this?
They might as well be doing.
My Dad is the greatest.
If nothing else comes from this,
from this little Avatar of you because
I want him to Jocko approved like an
amulet of your head. Yeah. This shirt.
It has one right in the back. Okay, cool.
Yeah, it's good. Yeah. They'd
kettle bell should be his head.
Cause the reason he got it was
because I had a heavier Kettlebell by
happenstance. By the way, I didn't
get there. Everyone just, sorry.
Is this a Kettlebell I can buy from Jocko?
Jocko bought a bag or your
kettle was about to say,
which it reminds me every time I'm
about to talk about kettlebells.
Kettlebells I have, you know the ones
from Onnit. Yeah, I got all of them. Yeah,
me too. Except I don't have
the big foot one, two bad eggs.
I can't pick that one up. It's just
too heavy. Yeah. Prosthetics. Yeah.
No I dig it and I haven't picked
up anything for over a year anyway.
So that's what I was trying to imply to
Jocko that like since mine is heavy I
can pick it up. He can't pick it up,
et cetera. Two pounds. Everything is.
So that's why he got the heavier one.
Roger that. Yeah, I'm tracking now.
I'm dragging her in six pounds.
Yeah. Congratulations. Yeah.
Cause this was a custom made kettlebell.
No. Got It from rogue fitness. Rogue,
right? Yeah. My boys at rogue fitness.
But it's like made in America.
It's like the boring round one. You know,
you said you have the, um, I got the ones.
Yeah. That's why I thought you meant
the Jocko was coming out with a,
with a Kettlebell. I, she will obviously
it's going to be shaped like Jockos.
[inaudible]. That's my, that's my,
because they could do that and now I think
a product was just born. Yeah. Maybe.
Actually someone, someone said that a
couple of times. Anyway. I agree. I agree.
It was the longest commercial.
Everybody, it's not a commercial you,
we deviated from the commercial to
Roger, but I'm sorry. I'm sorry. No,
we're supposed to do that.
Okay. That's part of the
Deere, right? I know. I forgot.
I told you I'm in basic training
for life again. Nonetheless.
Back to the kettlebells.
If you get kettlebells.
Yeah.
In a way that's not competitive with
your friend or if it's competitive with
your friend, whatever, the ones from
on it. That's the cool ones. Judy,
as a whole set. I have the whole set.
If you have the whole set, you're cool.
Like us, not like Jocko. Also
when you get Jody's new book,
of course chocolate's book.
Any of the books we read,
go or go over on the podcast.
I made it easy for you got a section on
the website? Yeah. Books from the website.
Got them all listed by episode by
the way. Nice. Speak through there.
Get them through there. Real easy.
A good way to support as well.
That'll take you to Amazon.
Just say sorry real quick.
Unflinching the making of a Canadian
sniper and everyday heroes. Yeah,
my two books. They'll both
be on the website. Yeah.
Write down your website and they are
available through Amazon and what's the
kindle? They have recalls on kindle.
Kindle. That's Amazon too a think. Yeah.
Everywhere at like audio book.
Yeah. This stuff. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well I'll have it all on the website,
so yeah, when you get that boom,
click through there. It's way easier
for you. Fence, good way to support.
If you want to continue shopping on
Amazon to buy your weed whackers and what
else? We buy an Amazon. Go ahead
and do that too. Good way also.
Yeah,
subscribe to the podcast. If you haven't
already. Seems normal. Seems obvious.
Itunes, if you want to subscribe
as far as subscribing those,
it's about like what you listen.
Do you listen to iTunes? Oh yeah.
That's what it is.
Exclusively. Exactly right.
Some people they listen to Google play.
Can you subscribe on Google play though?
Okay. That's what I was getting at. I
don't know where else I get to spend.
It's the same thing. Yes, I do that and
then now there's different apps now.
Like they're basically stopped.
You're confusing. This is, okay.
Consider it this way and I,
this is, I'm new to this too.
Where iTunes when you think podcasts.
Yeah,
I iPod podcasts.
So podcasts are exclusive to iTunes.
It just feels that way. Right.
Where do you listen to podcasts? Well,
on iTunes obviously. Here's the thing,
podcast, the podcast, just cause I
tuned has, it's like if you watch out,
if I just went to the website, what's
your website again? Jocko podcast.com.
So if I go to Java, podcast.com could
I listen straight from the podcast?
From the story? From the website? Yes. On
my computer. Yes. Bob's, your uncle. Boom.
There it is here. And uh, I
did. Yes, I did not know that.
There's basically all these different
ways to listen to it and it whatever way
you choose to listen to it,
there's where you subscribe in the event
of these things offering the subscribe
option, which I think they all do. I'm not
sure cause I don't explore all of them.
It's just how it works. So what I'm saying
is if you want to subscribe, subscribe,
good way to support also on Youtube, which
we have a youtube channel by the way,
Judy medic Roger that not just
the video version of this podcast,
but excerpts and various creative
videos here and there and some outtakes.
By the way, I'm not many, but a
few. I'll put more up there. Also,
Jocko has a store, it's called
Jocko store chocolate store.com.
Obviously that's where we get,
or we make these shirts.
Jody see this shirt Jocko has on right
now the victory MMA and fitness. Yeah.
He always says that turned on by the
way. He does that. Well, not last night.
That's why I was there was underneath
my Roger that. Yeah, I was gonna say,
how did you even recognize?
That's why I wore my friends.
So this is a tactical beaver
shirt and it's a Canadian company.
Started by cans off guys could dudes. I
was going to wear this last night. Yeah,
but I didn't,
I thought jogger would show up and tee
shirts so I stayed in a t shirt. Yeah.
Yeah. And anyway, so now he's in
a tee shirt and I'm in the color.
You're all dressed up. Damn man. Anyway,
that's the tactical beaver was my
last podcast. If you listen. Yeah,
they were on the show. It's good. It was
pretty dope. You know what else is dope?
The shirt Juncos on and the shirt
I have on with chocolate hit on it.
And if you want this shirt,
Jocko,
store.com there's a lot of
shirts on their disability.
I have a green and black
one in my suitcase back in
the hotel of that one. Boom.
I thought it'd be weird where and your
shirt hanging out with you though. Yeah,
I thought so.
But there's a deeper meaning.
I think the fact that Jockos head
is on my shirt and I'm sitting now,
you're part of this show,
so you gotta wear it. Oh,
I'll wear it if there's an echo shirt.
I need five immediately.
I have four friends and myself that want
that shirt. Oh, all right. There you go.
You got it. Sorry man. I've been, I've
been unplugged since May. Basically.
Sorry man. You got to unplug sometimes.
That's my, that's it. You know what?
And that's going back. Yeah. I think plug,
I'm going on Facebook while personal.
I'm going to keep the business side,
but you got personal stuff is goes anyway.
Can finish what you're doing. I'm sorry.
I know you're part of what we're doing.
I'm not gonna read a list of things
that you should or should not do.
I'm gonna be, I'm gonna ask you about it.
I'm massive Jocko about it. Chocolate.
Tell me to hurry up. I may or may not
hurry up and whatever. That's how it,
that's how it always
works. Nonetheless, Jocko,
store.com any shirt you
want and I need to shout,
I'm going to go into that
right after the show. Yes.
There's also some patches on there,
some hoodies, rash guards, hats,
women's stuff on their kids.
Stuff on there. It's a good,
good thing he's a beanies are on their
way. If you go like well, you figure well,
beanies could very well be on there.
They're on there.
Do you wear a beanie when it's
cold outside? When it's cold out?
It's not a fashion statement
for you. Okay. Just checking.
I was here to win, man.
Here. The wind, no fashion. No, sure. It
looks good though, Bro. For sure. Anyway,
chocolate store.com I'm not saying go
buy something. I'm not saying that,
but you should,
but if you like something,
you get something that's a
good way to support. Also,
I don't know if you know about this. You
might, I dunno. Psychological warfare.
Is that ringing a bell? I
mean, I know what it is.
Is this something that's an
unfortunate statement? Yeah,
so psychological warfare is an
album that we created with tracks.
Jocko turn. Ah, playlist. Yes.
A platelet playlist. Yeah.
I prefer mixtape. Mixtape. Yeah. Yeah.
Mix tape of Jocko was hurt. Yeah,
essentially. But here it's for a
specific reason. Right, right, right.
It's not him playing the
Ukulele. Ukulele. No, indeed.
It's him telling you how to get
through certain weak moments. Oh,
is it his is his moment,
his videos? No. No. Better.
More specific. So here, here's what it
is. Good. I'm actually glad you don't.
You don't know the specifics of it
because they'll can talk about it for 28
minutes. It's actually number one
on iTunes by the way. But you know,
oh that guy downloaded that. I never
listened to it though. Sorry Bro.
You don't need it.
I just wanted to for my friend
[inaudible] you gave the support. Yeah,
that's okay. But I probably should
have let it support you too.
I probably should have this really what
it's for to support you. I used to,
you know how like,
you know when you work out and you
don't feel like working out or you go to
workout and you don't feel like Philly
that for the last 18 months with,
you know what? I'll do it tomorrow. Yeah,
I've been saying that his last October.
All right, with you. Well they over
2016 I've been saying that. So they got,
I thought that was my biggest
weakness. I come to Jocko, I said,
what are you doing? You don't feel
like working out. I mean I know. Cool.
Your top work out. Yeah. And then will
show, but there's more to it than that.
It's not that simple. You know?
And he explained it. I said,
you know what we're going to do? We're
going to record that. And is that,
that was the birth of the psychological
warfare. Exactly what it is.
I did download it actually
when it came out, I just,
I forgot I even had it look at the tracks.
Here's what you do.
Look at the tracks and be like,
cause it's not just missing workout.
It's like procrastination, uh,
on a pro at that now. Yeah.
So like I got my black belt
and procrastination bro. Yeah.
So consider one that you're like,
okay, not only will it help,
it will 100% get you through it, Roger
that it's been the case for me anyway.
Get in.
You can get that on iTunes of course,
and anywhere where they sell
mp3s, Amazon music, whatnot.
It's a good one.
Couple other things on Amazon.
You can get Jocko white tea.
It's no big deal unless you want
to dead lift 8,000 pounds minimum.
Then you drink Jocko white tea and
you're there. No questions asked.
100% guaranteed that though
if you want to get some books,
you can get Jody mix books.
There's two of them.
Unflinching the making of a Canadian
Canadian sniper and also his latest book,
Everyday Heroes,
which is war stories from the generations
edited by Jodi.
You get way of the warrior kid so you
can teach kids to do the right things in
their lives.
You know things like beyond the path,
it's all, I'm going to say discipline
equals freedom field manual.
That book. Yeah. It's about
getting on the path and staying on
the path. That's what it's about.
Not going to say anything else about
that one. I will accept for that.
The audio version of that book
is not on audible. It is on
anywhere. You can get an MP three which
means iTunes, Amazon music, Google play,
and then of course the first book,
extreme ownership,
combat leadership. There's a
new version out. It's black,
which makes it a little bit cooler.
You can get that. Learn how to lead.
Also beyond the books and the podcast.
If you need leadership,
let's say leadership guidance
and direction at your company,
at Your Business or at your team.
I have a leadership and
management consulting company.
It's called echelon front and that is what
we do. We'd come to your organization.
We assessed the situation and we get
problems solved through leadership.
It's me,
it's my brother Leif Babin that wrote
extreme ownership with me who was one of
the platoon commanders that served
with me in the battle of Ramadi.
It's JP Denelle who was the point man
and the lead sniper of Delta platoon in
the battle of Ramadi.
It's Dave Burke,
who was an f 18 marine corps
fighter pilot, top gun pilot,
top gun instructor, top
gun, senior instructor,
F 16 pilot f 18 pilot f
35 pilot f 22 pilot first.
He sounds like he's pretty
good at his job. He's not bad.
He's the first operational squadron
commander for the [inaudible].
He's the only man in the world
qualified to fly all those aircraft.
But none of that matters because what
he did was cool was he was on the ground
with us in the battle of Ramadi as a
Anglico team leader with his team and was,
uh, with what, what is an Anglico?
It's, it's the guys that call for fire.
They, yeah, they're Jay tax book.
The Marine Corps has Anglico,
but they call it Anglico air naval
gunfire liaison. Roger that. Yup.
And that's what he did for us.
Outstanding Guy.
He's been on the podcast number
60, number 69, I believe.
So he's part of the echelon front
team as well. Also on top of that,
there's the muster is the
leadership seminar with us,
the Echelon Front team again,
uh,
in 2018 we're only doing two masters.
People think we're going
on with rock and roll tour.
We're not going on a rock and roll tour.
We're not going city to city is
not going to happen in Cleveland.
It's not going to happen in Milwaukee.
It's not going to happen.
It's not going to happen in San
Diego this year. It's an alert.
Can we go to places?
It's going to happen in Washington DC,
May 17th and 18th so that's where you go.
If you're on the east coast,
east of the Mississippi,
you come to DC, what day?
May 17th and 18th if you're
west of the Mississippi,
you come to San Francisco October
17th 17th and 18th that's it.
Like I said,
we're not going anywhere else.
So the reason is because we
don't have time to do them.
It's to get all the echelon front
team together and set it all up.
It's very hard to do because we're working
with clients all over the country and
all over the world.
So we can't just do musters all the time,
so that's where we're doing two of them.
If you want to come sign up,
all the four of them we, we, that
we've had so far have all sold out.
These are going to sell out to
100% so if you want to come,
you've got to go and register to attend
extreme ownership.com can I reserve two
spots where you knew in
Washington? Yes, you can. All
right, cool. Cool, cool. We do.
Yeah.
Jody plus one until then,
until the muster.
If you have questions or answers for us
or you just want to check in and share
your wins. I noticed people do that now
on social media. You share the wins. Yeah,
I got this promotion.
I overcame this little situation.
They give a little brief on the situation.
Hey,
I had this guy that was acting wrong. I
took ownership and boom, problem solved.
I lost weight,
I gained weight.
I got a stripe on my white belt in
Jujitsu and I'm proud and I am proud.
I'm stoked when you get that stripe
on the white belt or the blue belt.
Sometimes people get the black belt brown
belt. But what we see is progression.
Yeah. Like I said, people lose weight.
People gain weight. People stay clean.
People stay off the sauce.
People stay off the drugs.
People stay on the path. And if you want
to check in with us about that stuff,
you can do it on Twitter,
on Instagram and on Dat
Pham Bull Hace Blah.
Jodi is at Jody Mitic,
j.
O. D. Y M. I t.
I c echo is at Echo Charles
and I am at Jockowillink Echo.
Any closing thoughts? No. Thank you for
coming on and it's great to see you again.
You too bro. Mr Jody Mitic,
you got anything else?
Tiago, thank you for giving
me the mic back for five
minutes. No, I'm just kidding.
Uh, I just want to say thanks to
you, uh, for bringing me on today.
Uh, I know you did this cause you
didn't have to cause you wanted to and I
appreciate that and I need to do
this. Let go of, uh, as always,
you should stop drinking, by the way. Um,
I mean, now that I'm a reformed drinker,
that's the, that's the, that's the,
that's the answer to everything. Yeah.
Just stop it. Just stop
drinking. Surprisingly. It's
the, it's the big answer.
It's a good, a lot of philosophy.
I agree with, you know,
if you look at that study that comes out,
I forget who does it.
I think it's the UN at the
most destructive force on
earth is alcohol above coke,
heroin, speed, crack at all. Put together.
Booze is still 10 times worse,
like when it comes because it's
available to everybody. Right? Yeah. Um,
I should thank everybody that been
with me through this. You know,
sometimes you think you're
alone and you're not a,
I've had friends and family that
have not stopped. Basically,
you feel like they're bugging
you, but they're not. They're
keeping an eye on you.
Um, uh, and all the supporters and
the fans and the, and just the,
the, the Jody Mitic fans. Thank
you for being there for me.
Thank you for being honest with
me and thank you to my friends.
And my family for putting
up with me. And, um,
I fell off the path if I lost
my bearing pretty bad. Uh,
but now I've reoriented the
map and I'm back on track and,
uh, give me, give me some
time. The Jody Mitic podcast,
we'll be back up and
running in short order.
Give me six weeks ish and we should
have to be pumping out some episodes.
Who knows? Maybe I'll fly Jocko up
to Ottawa and we'll do an episode.
I don't know.
The point is something will be
coming and there's a few hardcore,
I'm talking granite hard fans that have
like stuck it out and they send us at
least a tweet a week to be like,
where are you bitches at?
And we're coming back
quick. Um, just real quick,
shout out to my friends at tactical
beaver. If you want some of their stuff,
just go on tactical beaver.
Yes, like the animal. Uh,
you can get some of their gear.
It's pretty cool. A Canadian twist,
a Canadian flavor.
And if you're,
if you're the one guy in your unit
that has it and you're not Canadian,
you might be a, you might be popular
for a minute. But, um, and uh, you know,
and the last thing,
uh,
goes out to my kids ala and
Kira Ala's nine peanut curious,
six squeaky. Uh, they're waiting
for me at home very patiently.
And uh,
as soon as daddy's home,
we're going to go to Jujitsu
because daddy needs to learn too.
And I know you guys don't like it now,
but when you're older you will appreciate
it. And for the rest of everybody else,
um, we're going to look in the camera
for a minute. Echo. You can edit that in,
right? Sure. Um,
I know I've said sorry before I'll
say it again and again. Thank you.
I will say over and over
again for supporting me and
it's because of people like
Jocko and rob who you'll meet who's a
green baret and some other very special
people in my life that I am found a
reason to get back to being myself in.
Yeah. And uh, and that's about it.
That's all I can say. Thank you man.
Awesome brother.
Well,
it's awesome having you back on again
and you'll be coming back on again and
again as you continued on this,
this journey on
better and I and we can just keep
burrowing down and helping others.
It's all good. My next book
comes out, I will come back.
That's awesome. And so thanks for coming
on. It's awesome to see you again.
And like I said,
we'll,
we'll keep doing this for the
next 20 years and finally,
thanks to all the service men
and women out there right now.
Okay.
Right now,
think about that right now.
Right this moment in time there's men
and women out there on the front lines
face to face with evil.
So thanks to you all for protecting
us and our freedoms and to the police,
law enforcement,
firefighters,
paramedics and the rest
of the first responders.
Thanks for your service and your
sacrifice to keep us safe here at home.
Yeah.
And to everyone that's out there grinding,
working,
driving trucks,
pouring concrete,
hammering on a project,
building bridges or building software,
sewing some garments or
sewing of field farmers,
factory workers, engineers, electricians,
plumbers at pilots and ground crew and
cooks and waitresses to everyone out
there working hard and listening to
this and just trying to get yourself a
little bit better today
than you were yesterday.
Thanks for listening.
And
as you meet struggles
and as you struggle to stay on the path,
first of all,
remember you don't have to fight alone.
Reach out to your comrades in arms,
call for
fire,
support when you need it.
We win wars because we stick
together and when we stick together,
we can overcome any enemy
and the struggles that you face.
Yeah.
When they, when they do try to flank, you
do what Jody did.
Do what a soldier does.
Turn into the ambush,
turn toward the enemy,
fire and attack.
And until next time,
this is Jody,
medic and echo and Jocko
out.